This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. In the summer of 1776, 33-year-old Thomas Jefferson drafted one of the most important documents in the history of the United States. The Declaration of Independence laid out a vision for a new country and said all men had God-given rights to life, liberty, and the pursuit of happiness. to life, liberty, and the pursuit of happiness. Eighty-six changes to the draft were made by John Adams, Ben Franklin, and others. Like many writers, Thomas Jefferson is said to have been unhappy with the changes his editors recommended. But the line about how we are all entitled to the pursuit of happiness endured. In recent years, many elements of the Declaration
这是Hidden Brain。我是Shankar Vedantam。1776年夏天，33岁的托马斯·杰斐逊起草了美国历史上最重要的文件之一。《独立宣言》为这个新国家描绘了愿景，并宣称所有人都有上帝赋予的生命权、自由权和追求幸福的权利。约翰·亚当斯、本·富兰克林等人对草案进行了86处修改。据说，像许多作家一样，托马斯·杰斐逊对编辑们建议的修改并不满意。但关于我们都有权追求幸福的那一行字却保留了下来。近年来，许多关于《独立宣言》的元素
of Independence have come under scrutiny, including its omission of women, the poor, and enslaved people. We've examined some of these ideas in an earlier episode that looked at Thomas Jefferson's complicated life story. Today on the show, we continue our U2.0 series with a favorite episode that explores Jefferson's psychological claim about what makes for a good life.
受到了审视，包括它忽略了女性、穷人和被奴役的人。我们在之前的一期节目中探讨过其中一些观点，那期节目审视了托马斯·杰斐逊复杂的人生故事。今天在节目中，我们继续我们的U2.0系列，带来一期备受喜爱的节目，探讨杰斐逊关于什么造就美好生活的心理学主张。
What happens in our minds when we pursue happiness? This week on Hidden Brain. When you ask people what they want in life, nearly everyone will tell you they want to be happy. After all, that's the point of finding a great job, starting a family, or going on wonderful vacations. At the University of California, Berkeley, finding a great job, starting a family, or going on wonderful vacations. At the University of California, Berkeley, psychologist Iris Moss studies a paradox associated with our pursuit of happiness.
当我们追求幸福时，我们的内心发生了什么？本周的Hidden Brain。当你问人们想要什么生活时，几乎每个人都会告诉你他们想要幸福。毕竟，找到一份好工作、组建家庭或去度假的意义就在于此。在加州大学伯克利分校，心理学家Iris Moss研究了与我们追求幸福相关的一个悖论。
Iris Moss, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Iris, about a decade ago, you achieved a major milestone in the life of a scholar. You got tenure at a great university. How long had you dreamed of becoming a professor at a school like UC Berkeley? I think forever. So this was a really big deal for me. I'd been working toward this for a long time and had been really looking forward to that moment,
Iris Moss，欢迎来到Hidden Brain。非常感谢邀请我。Iris，大约十年前，你作为学者达到了一个重要的里程碑。你在名校获得了终身教职。你梦想在像加州大学伯克利分校这样的学校成为教授有多久了？我想是永远。所以这对我很重要。我为此努力了很久，一直非常期待那一刻，
hoping I would get tenure. Getting tenure is a big deal, of course. I would get to be with the most lovely colleagues I could imagine and doing what I love in a beautiful area. Now, whenever I visit UC Berkeley, I'm struck by how beautiful it is. I mean, Berkeley really is absolutely gorgeous. So mission accomplished, Iris? Well, not quite. It wasn't quite the way that I had imagined. It's sort of like the saying, wherever you go, there you are. So I was still the same person somehow and worries and stressful things still happened.
希望我能获得终身教职。当然，获得终身教职是一件大事。我将能与我能想象到的最可爱的同事们在一起，并在一个美丽的地方做我热爱的事情。现在，每当我访问加州大学伯克利分校，我都会被它的美丽所震撼。我的意思是，伯克利真的很美。那么，任务完成了，Iris？嗯，不完全是。它并不完全是我想象的那样。这有点像那句谚语，无论你去哪里，你都在那里。所以我不知何故还是同一个人，担忧和压力依然存在。
Although at first, at least in the sort of year after getting tenure, those sort of small worries hit me almost more than before because they had this element of, wait a minute, shouldn't I be happy all the time? Is there something wrong with me that I have tenure now, and yet I still have worries in my life? I understand you had a similar experience more recently, Iris,
虽然起初，至少在获得终身教职后的那一年里，那些小小的担忧几乎比以前更强烈地冲击着我，因为它们带有一种“等等，我不应该一直快乐吗？”的成分。我获得终身教职了，为什么生活里还有担忧？是不是我出了什么问题？我知道你最近也有类似的经历，Iris，
when you took a trip to the Italian island of Sardinia. What was your state of anticipation before the trip? This was the first trip I took in a really long time, and I was going to get together with my very oldest childhood friend. She lives in Germany. I hadn't seen her in two years and we had this trip planned. I thought this is just gonna be amazing. I'm gonna be relaxing. I'm gonna be happy.
当你去意大利撒丁岛旅行时。旅行前你的期待状态是什么样的？这是我很久以来第一次旅行，我要去见我童年最好的朋友。她住在德国。我已经两年没见她了，我们计划了这次旅行。我想这一定会很棒。我会放松，我会快乐。
I visualized it almost like one of those Tuscan Italian movies. You know, we would be on the beach, we would be drinking wine, eating delicious food. We would go boating around the little island and just floating happily in those beautiful turquoise waters. So I had every expectation and so much anticipation
我几乎把它想象成那些托斯卡纳意大利电影中的场景。你知道，我们会躺在沙滩上，喝着红酒，吃着美味的食物。我们会乘船环绕小岛，在美丽的绿松石海水中快乐地漂浮。所以我满怀期待，
that it would be just the perfect 10 days. So what happened Iris? Well, we had a lovely time, but little thoughts or moments snuck in where I would be thinking about work or I would worry about something going on at home. So these little thoughts started to appear and I would think, wait a minute, this isn't right. This isn't supposed to be here, this thought. What's going on?
觉得那将是完美的10天。那么发生了什么，Iris？嗯，我们度过了一段美好的时光，但一些小想法或瞬间会溜进来，我会想到工作，或者担心家里发生的事情。所以这些小想法开始出现，我会想，等等，这不对。这个想法不应该出现在这里。怎么回事？
Have I lost the ability to relax? Is there something wrong with me? Is there something wrong with the vacation? Why am I not happy every moment of every day? So you're on this trip with your childhood friend and her partner. Did your restlessness affect your travel companions too? I think I maybe I drove them a tiny little nutty because I started to suggest sort of all kinds of things to bring about the continuous happy state that I had anticipated. So I would say, let's go to this other beach today, or let's
我失去放松的能力了吗？是我出了问题吗？是假期出了问题吗？为什么我不能每时每刻都快乐？所以你和你的童年好友以及她的伴侣一起旅行。你的不安也影响了你的旅伴吗？我想我可能把他们弄得有点抓狂，因为我开始建议各种各样的事情来维持我所预期的那种持续的快乐状态。所以我会说，今天去另一个海滩吧，或者
rent a boat and go around this little island, or let's go to a different restaurant. And maybe that was a little bit much for them. I have a colleague who describes vacations like this as march or die. There's no sitting in one place. You either march or or die. There's no sitting in one place you either march or you die. A little bit like that. I want to ask you about another episode in your life, Iris, and I think this one reveals how our approach to pursuing happiness is something we do not only for ourselves but something we encourage in other people, including our kids.
租条船环绕这个小岛，或者去另一家餐厅。也许这对他们来说有点过分了。我有一位同事把这样的假期描述为“行军或死亡”。没有坐在一个地方的说法。你要么行军，要么死亡。有点像那样。我想问你关于你生活中的另一件事，Iris，我认为这件事揭示了我们追求幸福的方式不仅是为了自己，也是我们鼓励他人（包括我们的孩子）去做的事情。
Back home in the Bay Area, you got busy throwing a party for your son's eighth birthday. What were the preparations for the party like? I mean, I always try to make his birthday parties really nice, but this one in particular, I wanted it to be perfect. And so I had reserved a picnic spot at the local park. I got a coronavirus piñata, where you sort of bash a piñata that looks like a coronavirus, filled it with candy, lots of games that I had thought of, and decorations, of course. My friend who's an amazing baker made this
回到湾区的家中，你忙着为儿子八岁生日举办派对。派对的准备工作是怎样的？我的意思是，我总是尽力让他的生日派对办得很好，但这次我特别想让它变得完美。所以我预订了当地公园的野餐点。我买了一个冠状病毒皮纳塔，就是那种你可以敲打看起来像冠状病毒的皮纳塔，里面装满了糖果，还有我想到的一大堆游戏，当然还有装饰品。我的一位朋友是一位出色的烘焙师，她做了这个
enormous stunning cake and of course we had pizza. And when you visualize what this party would be like I'm imagining you saw your son just basically being ecstatic the whole time and frolicking and playing with his friends. That's exactly right. Ecstatic the whole time, frolicking, bathed in golden rays of sunlight, exactly like that. MUSIC
巨大而惊艳的蛋糕，当然我们还有披萨。当你想象这个派对会是什么样子时，我猜你想象的是你的儿子一直都很兴奋，和朋友们嬉戏玩耍。完全正确。一直都很兴奋，嬉戏，沐浴在金色的阳光下，完全就是那样。音乐
So I almost hesitate to ask you the question question given the pattern that we're starting to see here Iris, but how did the party turn out when you arrived on the big day? Well, the first thing that happened was that this is in June and it never rains in the Bay Area in June, never, except that one day. And it was raining the morning of the party. Um, so we had to sort of switch gears. So I sort of texted everybody come a little later, hoping, crossing my fingers, so it would stop raining.
所以我几乎不敢问你这个问题，考虑到我们在这里看到的模式，Iris，但当你在大日子到达时，派对结果如何？嗯，发生的第一件事是，那是六月，湾区的六月从不下雨，从来没有，除了那一天。派对那天早上在下雨。嗯，所以我们不得不改变计划。所以我给每个人发短信说晚点来，祈祷着雨能停。
We still went to the park to set up because my son was very impatient and intent on having his party. So we go in the rain, we're setting everything up, we're getting drenched. And of course people, I told them to come a little later, but my son had the start time of the party in his head, 11 o'clock. And 11 o'clock comes, nobody is there yet, and he starts to lose it. And I still sort of have that image in my head of him sort of standing in the rain, getting drenched falling and You must have felt like your heart was breaking because you had put so much time and effort and thought into making this the perfect party Yeah, I was really upset
我们还是去了公园布置，因为我儿子很不耐烦，一心想办他的派对。所以我们在雨中布置，全身湿透。当然，我告诉人们晚点来，但我儿子脑子里记着派对开始的时间是11点。11点到了，还没人来，他开始崩溃了。我脑海中依然有他站在雨中，全身湿透的样子，你一定觉得心碎，因为你投入了这么多时间和精力去筹划这个完美的派对。是的，我真的很沮丧。
but it did stop raining and We went ahead and other things went wrong. Of course The pinata, you know, had gotten drenched in rain and so when the piñata bashing was supposed to happen, it took just one swing and the whole thing just sort of sadly flopped down. And kids, they didn't want to play the games that I had planned for them. They did their own thing and it was a big disappointment and sort of like bordering on disaster. When my son was bawling standing in the rain, I thought, wow, this is actually the worst birthday party ever. What Iris did is something we all do.
但雨确实停了，我们继续进行，当然其他事情也出了差错。你知道，皮纳塔被雨淋透了，所以当应该进行敲打皮纳塔环节时，只敲了一下，整个东西就悲哀地瘫软下来。孩子们不想玩我为他们计划的游戏。他们玩他们自己的，这真是一个巨大的失望，简直接近灾难。当我的儿子站在雨中嚎啕大哭时，我想，哇，这真的是有史以来最糟糕的生日派对。Iris所做的是我们所有人都会做的事。
We dream about what it would feel like to accomplish something, to get something, or to be somewhere. We imagine how it would feel if we got into a great school, or found a great job, or fell in love with the perfect person who loved us back. Sometimes when those dreams don't work out, we are heartbroken. But even when they do work out, we often feel let down,
我们梦想着完成某件事、得到某样东西或身处某个地方会是什么感觉。我们想象如果我们进入了一所名校，或者找到了一份好工作，或者爱上了一个也爱我们的完美伴侣，那会是什么感觉。有时当这些梦想没有实现时，我们会心碎。但即使它们实现了，我们也常常感到失望，
cheated. We achieved this difficult thing, obtained this amazing relationship, accomplished our dreams. Why, we find ourselves asking, are we not happier? When we come back, the problem with our theory of happiness. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Iris Moss has first-hand experience about what it feels like to chase a dream only to feel let down when she obtained it. In her research as a
被欺骗了。我们完成了这件困难的事，获得了这段美妙的关系，实现了我们的梦想。我们发现自己会问，为什么我们没有更快乐？回来后，我们将探讨关于幸福理论的问题。你正在收听Hidden Brain。我是Shankar Vedantam。这是Hidden Brain，我是Shankar Vedantam。Iris Moss有亲身经历，知道追逐梦想却在得到它时感到失望是什么感觉。作为加州大学伯克利分校的
psychologist at UC Berkeley, she has run a number of experiments to try to understand the phenomenon. Iris, lots of our listeners are people who are used to working hard to accomplish difficult things. If happiness is the most important goal of all, we tell ourselves, okay, let's work at it, let's accomplish it. You've studied people who chase after happiness in this way. What do studies reveal about their mental health and well-being? We found that people who are very intent on being happy,
心理学家，她进行了一系列实验来试图理解这种现象。Iris，我们的许多听众都是习惯于努力工作以完成困难任务的人。如果幸福是所有目标中最重要的，我们告诉自己，好吧，让我们为此努力，让我们实现它。你研究过以这种方式追求幸福的人。研究揭示了他们的心理健康和幸福感如何？我们发现，那些非常执着于快乐的人，
those same people, somewhat somewhat ironically in general have lower levels of well-being, higher levels of depressive symptoms, and paradoxically lower levels of overall happiness. So it seems that the more perhaps the more intent they are on being happy, the less they actually manage to be happy. So your research has identified several reasons for this. One has to do with the effects of high expectations. And perhaps we've heard some echoes of this in the stories you told us about becoming a tenured professor at UC Berkeley or the vacation in Italy.
这些人，讽刺的是，总体上幸福感水平较低，抑郁症状水平较高，而且矛盾的是，整体幸福感水平也较低。所以似乎他们越是执着于快乐，他们实际上就越难获得快乐。所以你的研究确定了几个原因。一个与高期望的影响有关。也许我们在你讲述关于成为加州大学伯克利分校终身教授或意大利度假的故事中听到了一些回响。
What is the role of high expectations in shaping our experience of happiness, Iris? High expectations in other life domains can be a good thing, right? We might strive toward doing really well in school and then we work hard toward getting a good grade. We might fall short of it, feel disappointed, and that might motivate us to work harder. But in the domain of happiness, there's sort of a paradox there, right? In that if we're disappointed when falling short of our goal that
高期望在塑造我们的幸福体验中扮演什么角色，Iris？高期望在生活的其他领域可能是一件好事，对吧？我们可能会努力在学校表现出色，然后努力争取好成绩。我们可能会达不到目标，感到失望，这可能会激励我们更加努力。但在幸福领域，这存在一种悖论，对吧？因为如果我们因未达到目标而感到失望，
we're striving for, the high standard, that disappointment in itself contradicts the very goal. So the more we strive toward the goal of happiness, the more we undermine our ability to actually get there. And of course, once you actually get there, even if the experience is very good but not perfect, it might still fall short of the very high expectations we had. Yeah, that's exactly right. So you've cited a study carried out by the psychologist Jonathan Schoohler and his colleagues. They studied people getting ready to celebrate the start of a new year. Tell me what the study found, Iris. Yeah, so this was
我们所追求的高标准，那种失望本身就与目标背道而驰。所以我们越是追求幸福这个目标，就越会削弱我们真正实现它的能力。当然，一旦你真正达到了目标，即使体验非常好但不完美，它可能仍然达不到我们所拥有的极高期望。是的，完全正确。所以你引用了心理学家Jonathan Schoohler及其同事进行的一项研究。他们研究了准备庆祝新年到来的人们。告诉我这项研究发现了什么，Iris。是的，所以这是
actually for New Year's Eve 2000, so it was a particularly big one. And a lot of people had really high expectations for what the big millennial New Year's Eve celebration would bring. And they asked people ahead of time how happy they expected to be and how much time they spent planning for the New Year's Eve celebration. First on, they found that 83% of people were actually disappointed with the celebration. And then the second really interesting thing that they found is that the more enjoyment participants expected having, the more disappointed they actually ended up being. So it's not like greater expectation and working more toward enjoying the party would pay off
实际上是2000年的除夕，所以这是一个特别大的日子。很多人对千禧年除夕庆祝活动会带来什么抱有很高的期望。他们提前询问人们期望自己有多快乐，以及他们花了多少时间计划除夕庆祝活动。首先，他们发现83%的人实际上对庆祝活动感到失望。然后他们发现的第二个非常有趣的事情是，参与者期望获得的快乐越多，他们最终感到的失望就越大。所以并不是说更高的期望和为享受派对付出更多努力就会带来
with greater enjoyment. Actually the exact opposite happened. More expectation, less enjoyment. I'm assuming this means that people who plan bigger parties might paradoxically have been less happy than people with smaller gatherings. That's exactly what they found. There's another reason that chasing happiness
更大的享受。实际上恰恰相反。期望越高，享受越少。我假设这意味着计划更大派对的人反而可能比参加小型聚会的人更不快乐。他们发现的正是如此。还有另一个原因，追逐幸福
can have the inadvertent effect of chasing it away. What is the effect of checking to see if we are happy on our experience of happiness? Checking how happy we are is very much so bound up with thinking that happiness is an important thing. And it's also something that we do, I think, very automatically. In all of the examples, I think,
可能会产生无意中将其赶走的副作用。检查我们是否快乐对我们的幸福体验有什么影响？检查我们有多快乐与认为幸福是一件重要的事情紧密相连。而且我认为这也是我们非常自动地做的事情。在我从自己生活中举出的所有例子中，
that I gave from my own life, it's very much so that the moment I checked in on how happy am I, how is this going, that's when I realized, oh, actually, I'm not quite as happy as I hoped to be. And various studies allude to that, or have examined that relationship between what's called experiences, hedonic experiences,
我意识到，当我检查自己有多快乐、进展如何的那一刻，我才意识到，哦，实际上，我并没有我希望的那么快乐。各种研究都暗示了这一点，或者研究了所谓的体验、享乐体验，
and metaconsciousness. So that sort of overlay of being self-consciously aware of how we're feeling. One domain of research where this has been examined is in the research of flow. And this is research by Mihaly Csikszenti-Mahri. He and colleagues have shown that when people are in a state of flow, they report later on being incredibly happy. So it's a state of deep happiness. But what's important is that it's also characterized by being completely unaware of the self. So it means that the self almost feels like it's dissolved during these states of flow.
与元意识之间的关系。也就是那种对我们感受进行自我意识的叠加。研究这一点的领域之一是“心流”研究。这是Mihaly Csikszenti-Mahri的研究。他和同事们已经证明，当人们处于心流状态时，他们事后报告说感到无比快乐。所以这是一种深层的幸福状态。但重要的是，它的特点也是完全没有自我意识。这意味着在这些心流状态下，自我几乎感觉消失了。
And in fact, it's interrupted and destroyed when you check in with yourself and ask, how am I feeling now? You know, I'm reminded of something that the 19th century philosopher John Stuart Mill once noticed. He said, ask yourself whether you are happy and you cease to be so.
事实上，当你审视自己并问“我现在感觉如何”时，它会被打断和破坏。你知道，我想起了19世纪哲学家约翰·斯图尔特·密尔曾经注意到的事情。他说，问问自己是否快乐，你就停止快乐了。
And that's saying exactly what you're suggesting, Iris, which is that the act of turning that spotlight inward and asking, am I happy, even when you are happy, it tends to have the effect of diminishing the experience of happiness. Yeah. So those ideas have been around for a long time. John Stuart Mill thought about hedonic experiences, of course, a lot. And there's another quote that I really like and that gets to the heart of another problem with striving too much to be happy. And he said, those only are happy who have
这正是你所暗示的，Iris，即把聚光灯转向内心并问“我快乐吗”的行为，即使当你确实快乐时，它往往也会产生削弱幸福体验的效果。是的。所以这些想法已经存在很长时间了。约翰·斯图尔特·密尔当然对享乐体验思考了很多。还有另一句我非常喜欢的名言，它触及了过度追求快乐的另一个问题的核心。他说，只有那些
their minds fixed on some object other than their own happiness, on the happiness of others, on the improvement of mankind, even on some art or pursuit, followed not as a means but as itself an ideal end. Aiming thus at something else, they find happiness by the way. And I really like that quote because it gets at another problem with overvaluing happiness or valuing it in the wrong way. And that's the idea that if we strive for our own happiness at the expense of what's going on around us, that's when things can go wrong and backfire.
将注意力集中在自身幸福以外的某个目标上的人，比如他人的幸福、人类的进步，甚至是某种艺术或追求，不是作为手段而是作为理想目标去追求的人，才是快乐的。这样瞄准其他目标，他们会在过程中找到幸福。我真的很喜欢这句话，因为它触及了过度重视幸福或以错误方式重视幸福的另一个问题。那就是，如果我们以牺牲周围发生的事情为代价来追求自己的幸福，那事情就会出错并适得其反。
In many ways, Iris, this gets to another idea I wanted to talk with you about, which is, is it possible that one reason pursuing happiness is an ineffective strategy is that we often don't know what it is that's going to make us happy. And so by pursuing things that we think will make us happy, we sometimes take our eye off the ball of the things that actually will make us happy.
在很多方面，Iris，这引出了我想和你谈论的另一个想法，那就是，追求幸福是一种无效策略的原因之一，是否可能是因为我们往往不知道什么会让我们快乐？因此，通过追求我们认为会让我们快乐的事情，我们有时会忽略了真正能让我们快乐的事情。
I think that's really right. Dan Gilbert and others have found that humans are actually pretty lousy at knowing what will make them happy. And one of the things that makes people most happy is spending time with others and being connected and close to other people. And sort of this overly intense pursuit of one's own happiness
我认为这非常正确。Dan Gilbert和其他人发现，人类在知道什么会让自己快乐方面其实相当糟糕。而让人最快乐的事情之一是与他人共度时光，建立联系并与他人亲近。而这种过度强烈的追求个人幸福，
that can come at the expense of connecting with other people. We did a study that gets at that question, asking whether if we don't pursue happiness in a way that sacrifices connection with other people, maybe we can get around the paradoxical effects of overvaluing happiness. And we took advantage of the fact that cultures differ with respect to what happiness tends to mean to people. And we sampled participants from cultures that are more socially oriented, East Asian cultures, Japan and Taiwan, all the way to cultures that tend to be more individualistically oriented, less socially oriented, the US.
可能会以牺牲与他人的联系为代价。我们做了一项研究来探讨这个问题，询问如果我们追求幸福的方式不牺牲与他人的联系，也许我们就能绕过过度重视幸福的悖论效应。我们利用了文化在幸福对人们意味着什么方面存在差异这一事实。我们从更注重社会导向的文化（东亚文化、日本和台湾）到往往更注重个人主义、社会导向较弱的文化（美国）中抽取了参与者。
Then we had two cultures in between Russia and Germany. In each of those samples, we asked participants how much they valued happiness, but also what happiness means to them. Then we looked at their overall levels of well-being. And what we found was really interesting because it suggests a way to get around that paradox that we've been talking about. So in the US, we found that valuing happiness was very much bound up with a more individualistic,
然后我们选取了处于中间的两种文化：俄罗斯和德国。在每个样本中，我们询问参与者他们有多重视幸福，以及幸福对他们意味着什么。然后我们观察了他们的整体幸福感水平。我们发现的结果非常有趣，因为它暗示了一种绕过我们一直在谈论的悖论的方法。在美国，我们发现重视幸福与更个人主义、
less social pursuit of happiness. And here we found that exact link that we've been talking about. The more people valued happiness, the less happy they were. But then as we went in the social direction on that gradient to Germany, to Russia, to East Asia, we found that pursuit of happiness was more and more connected with helping other people and being close with other people.
更少社会性的幸福追求紧密相连。在这里，我们发现了我们一直在谈论的那种联系。人们越重视幸福，他们就越不快乐。但随着我们沿着梯度向社会性方向发展，到德国、俄罗斯、东亚，我们发现对幸福的追求与帮助他人和与他人亲近的联系越来越紧密。
So what we found is that the more socially people interpret the value of happiness, the more that valuing happiness was associated with higher levels of well-being. So we've looked at several ways in which pursuing happiness in a very individualistic fashion can paradoxically make us less happy. It ramps up our expectations, which diminishes our satisfactions. It causes us to ask ourselves if we are happy, which is often not a good way to actually experience happiness. And it makes it more likely that we will turn away from others and experience loneliness. I want to talk about one other really important idea,
所以我们发现，人们对幸福价值的社会性解读越深，重视幸福就越与更高的幸福感水平相关联。所以我们已经审视了以非常个人主义的方式追求幸福在矛盾中使我们不快乐的几种方式。它提高了我们的期望，从而降低了我们的满足感。它导致我们问自己是否快乐，这通常不是真正体验幸福的好方法。而且它使我们更有可能背离他人并体验孤独。我想谈谈另一个非常重要的想法，
Iris. Besides chasing happiness, many of us also spend a great deal of time trying to escape unhappiness. I want to take you back to your days as a graduate student and have you tell us about the negative emotions you experienced whenever you had to make public presentations about your work? So like many people, I used to have anxiety about speaking in front of audiences. And as a psychology graduate student, when I first started to have to give research presentations, this anxiety was actually pretty intense, almost overwhelming at the time.
Iris。除了追逐幸福，我们许多人还花费大量时间试图逃避不快乐。我想带你回到你作为研究生的日子，让你告诉我们每当你不得不就你的工作进行公开演讲时所经历的负面情绪？像许多人一样，我曾经对在观众面前演讲感到焦虑。作为一名心理学研究生，当我第一次不得不进行研究报告时，这种焦虑实际上相当强烈，当时几乎让人难以承受。
And I remember particularly clearly, I think this was the first talk I had to give as a graduate student to faculty and other students in the area I was part of. So maybe a group of 30 people. So for weeks before that talk and any talk, I would have all these worries circling through my head about all the incredibly foolish things I would definitely say, how I would freeze, the sinking feeling of doom really, and lots of sleepless nights,
我记得特别清楚，我想这是我作为研究生第一次向我所在领域的教职员工和其他学生做报告。所以可能有一组30人。所以在演讲前几周，以及任何演讲前，我的脑海里都会盘旋着各种担忧，关于我肯定会说的所有极其愚蠢的话，我会如何僵住，那种沉没的厄运感，还有许多不眠之夜，
which doesn't particularly help. Um, so my approach was to think, well, wait a minute, I need to get rid of this anxiety telling myself it's just a speech. Come on, get it together. Um, try to ignore it, but, and I think this is pretty common, the anxiety would always return, and maybe even stronger than before, because it would then return along with the feeling
这并没有什么帮助。嗯，我的方法是想，好吧，等等，我需要摆脱这种焦虑，告诉自己这只是个演讲。来吧，振作起来。嗯，试着忽略它，但是，我认为这很常见，焦虑总是会回来，甚至可能比以前更强烈，因为它会伴随着一种感觉回来，
that it confirms there's something wrong about me. And this is so revealing, Iris, because what was happening here was not just that you were distressed but that you were distressed about being distressed. Yes so these were what's called negative meta-emotions so feelings about my feelings and those were almost worse maybe than the initial round of feelings because there's a saying that goes, pain is inevitable but suffering is optional.
即它证实了我身上有什么问题。这太有启发性了，Iris，因为这里发生的事情不仅是你感到痛苦，而且你对感到痛苦这件事感到痛苦。是的，所以这些被称为负面元情绪，即对我的感受的感受，而这些可能比最初的一轮感受更糟糕，因为有一句谚语说，痛苦是不可避免的，但受苦是可选的。
And these meta emotions, that's the suffering that we layer on top of negative emotions. Iris, I'm wondering, did these concerns and I guess these concerns about these concerns, were they serious enough that you started to think that maybe you were not cut out for this kind of career? Yeah, absolutely. Because giving research presentations
而这些元情绪，就是我们在负面情绪之上叠加的痛苦。Iris，我想知道，这些担忧，我想是关于这些担忧的担忧，是否严重到让你开始认为自己可能不适合这种职业？是的，绝对。因为进行研究报告
is a really big part of the job. And so it just became so bad that I considered dropping out of grad school. One of the things you just told me you did when you had these negative thoughts was to try and find ways to suppress them, to make them go away, and I think many of us do this. You've reviewed research that finds that ignoring or pushing away negative feelings can negatively affect how we relate to other people. Tell me about this research, Iris.
是这份工作非常重要的一部分。所以它变得太糟糕了，以至于我考虑退学。你刚才告诉我，当你产生这些负面想法时，你所做的事情之一就是试图找到压抑它们的方法，让它们消失，我想我们许多人都会这样做。你回顾的研究发现，忽视或推开负面情绪会负面影响我们与他人的关系。告诉我这项研究，Iris。
Yeah, so there's quite a bit of research on this, how suppressing our own emotions can be bad for ourselves, but also especially bad for interpersonal contexts. So in a recent study, we brought dating couples into the lab and we had them carry out two conversations. The first one, we wanted them to talk about something that is a problem in the relationship. So things like how often do you visit each other's families, disagreements about finances, disagreements about housework. And so the couples had basically a fight in the lab.
是的，关于压抑我们自己的情绪如何对我们自己有害，尤其是对人际关系环境有害，有很多研究。在最近的一项研究中，我们将约会中的情侣带到实验室，让他们进行了两次对话。第一次，我们想让他们谈论关系中的一个问题。比如你们多久拜访一次对方的家人，关于财务的分歧，关于家务的分歧。所以情侣们基本上在实验室里吵了一架。
And then we had them carry out a positive conversation where we told them to tell each other how much they appreciated one another and what they loved about one another. And those were lovely conversations. Now after each conversation, we asked them how much they had suppressed their feelings while they had talked with their romantic partner. And we also asked them how well they thought the conversation went and how connected they felt to one another.
然后我们让他们进行了一次积极的对话，我们告诉他们互相表达他们有多欣赏对方，以及他们爱对方什么。那些是可爱的对话。现在在每次对话后，我们询问他们在与浪漫伴侣交谈时压抑了多少感受。我们还询问了他们认为对话进行得如何，以及他们感到彼此联系有多紧密。
And what we found is that no matter whether we were looking at a fight or at the loving conversations, when people said that they had suppressed their emotions, and that was true for positive and for negative emotions, the more they suppressed them, the less they shared them with their partner, the less well the conversations went, and the less connected they felt to one another. So that suggests that holding back emotions,
我们发现，无论我们是在观察争吵还是充满爱意的对话，当人们说他们压抑了自己的情绪时，无论是积极情绪还是消极情绪，他们压抑得越多，他们与伴侣分享的就越少，对话进行得就越不顺利，他们感到彼此的联系就越少。所以这表明，压抑情绪，
even if it's negative emotions, seems to disturb social connection. superb social connection. As we've heard, chasing happiness in a highly individualistic manner does not work. Trying to elude unhappiness doesn't work either. When we come back, what does work? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. The conventional way most of us go about accomplishing anything is to work hard at it. When it comes to happiness, many of us say, if this is something I really want, I need to go out
即使是负面情绪，似乎也会干扰社会联系。正如我们所听到的，以高度个人主义的方式追逐幸福是行不通的。试图逃避不快乐也行不通。回来后，什么才行得通？你正在收听Hidden Brain。我是Shankar Vedantam。这是Hidden Brain，我是Shankar Vedantam。我们大多数人完成任何事情的传统方式是努力工作。当谈到幸福时，我们许多人说，如果这是我真正想要的，我需要走出去
and get it. This might be especially true in the United States where the Declaration of Independence celebrates the pursuit of happiness. The problem is pursuing happiness can have the paradoxical effect of chasing happiness away. Trying to elude unhappiness can be similarly counterproductive. Psychologist Iris Moss has spent many years asking herself what does work when it comes to living a happier life. A crucial moment of insight came from her own life. Yeah, so when my son was really little, baby, I'd say between six months, and maybe it went all the way till three years, he would have what is sometimes called witching
并得到它。这在美国可能尤其如此，因为《独立宣言》颂扬对幸福的追求。问题是，追求幸福可能会产生将幸福赶走的悖论效应。试图逃避不快乐也可能同样适得其反。心理学家Iris Moss花了很多年问自己，在过上更快乐的生活方面，什么才行得通。一个关键的洞察时刻来自她自己的生活。是的，所以当我儿子还很小的时候，婴儿，我会说在六个月到三岁之间，他会有有时被称为“巫婆时刻”的东西，
hour, which is exactly what it sounds like. It's long hours of crying and fussiness. And so he would cry, it's time to go to sleep, I needed to rest. I would rock him back to sleep and really, really gingerly put him in his crib and he would instantly wake back up and it would start over, repeating itself up to like two hours, maybe even more at a time.
这听起来是什么样就是什么样。那是长时间的哭闹和烦躁。所以他会哭，是时候睡觉了，我需要休息。我会把他摇回睡梦中，非常非常小心地把他放进婴儿床，他会立刻醒来，然后重新开始，重复长达两个小时，甚至更多。
And I remember being really distressed about it just because it's exhausting, unpleasant, but really thinking, here's my poor baby, he ought to sleep peacefully. What am I doing wrong? So just asking what's wrong with me, what's wrong with him? Why can't I get him to be peaceful, comforted? Why isn't he happy? And really the more frantically I'm trying to comfort him, the more upset he and I would become
我记得对此感到非常痛苦，仅仅是因为这让人筋疲力尽、不愉快，但真的在想，我可怜的宝宝，他应该安详地睡觉。我做错了什么？所以只是问我出了什么问题，他出了什么问题？为什么我不能让他平静、舒适？为什么他不快乐？真的，我越疯狂地试图安慰他，他和我就越不安，
sort of like a vicious cycle really. So there came a moment when you changed your approach to his distress. Tell me what happened, Iris. Yeah, so it kind of came to a head because I read one too many sleep advice books. You know, they all tell different advice. Keep a schedule, go with the flow, hold the baby, rock the baby, bounce the baby, blow
真的就像一个恶性循环。所以有一个时刻，你改变了处理他痛苦的方法。告诉我发生了什么，Iris。是的，因为我读了太多睡眠建议书，所以事情到了紧要关头。你知道，它们都提供不同的建议。保持时间表，顺其自然，抱着宝宝，摇晃宝宝，弹跳宝宝，对着宝宝吹
a hairdryer on the baby, keep it quiet, get the baby used to the noise, that kind of thing. And as a new parent, it really can drive you a little nutty. I think it just came to a point where I was reading all that and I'm like, I can't do this. And I realized in a way it was really not in my control because trying all these things hadn't yielded the expected, hoped-for effects. So in a way, I hit a wall and I had to accept what was.
吹风机，保持安静，让宝宝习惯噪音，诸如此类。作为新手父母，这真的会让你有点抓狂。我想这只是到了一个地步，我读了所有这些，我想我做不到。我意识到在某种程度上这真的不在我的控制范围内，因为尝试所有这些事情并没有产生预期的、希望的效果。所以从某种意义上说，我碰壁了，我必须接受现状。
What did you do differently once you had this realization? I didn't do anything differently, but my perspective on it changed. And I let go of the ought to control it, he ought to be peaceful, he ought to go to sleep, he ought to be happy. And that perspective change was almost like a little magic because the moment I changed my perspective, that very moment, a lot of the tension just left. He still cried. So it didn't change anything about the crying per se, but the moments or the times of crying
一旦你有了这个认识，你做了什么不同的事情？我没有做任何不同的事情，但我的观点改变了。我放下了“应该”控制它的想法，他应该安详，他应该去睡觉，他应该快乐。那种观点改变几乎就像一点魔法，因为我改变观点的那个时刻，就在那一刻，很多紧张感就消失了。他依然哭。所以它本身并没有改变关于哭泣的任何事情，但哭泣的时刻或时间
almost became pleasant. I mean, it's weird to say that, but it was almost pleasant because it wasn't something that I had to make go away that I was layering all this judgment on, but rather it was something that we shared. I thought, well, he's comfortable showing his distress to me. It sort of was an experience that we shared together and part of the richness of our relationship in a way, rather than something to try and avoid. So you went on to conduct research on the effects of practicing
几乎变得令人愉快。我的意思是，说这话很奇怪，但它几乎令人愉快，因为它不是我必须让它消失、我必须在上面叠加所有这些评判的东西，而是我们分享的东西。我想，好吧，他很舒服地向我展示他的痛苦。这在某种程度上是我们共同分享的经历，是我们关系丰富性的一部分，而不是试图避免的东西。所以你后来进行了关于练习
emotional acceptance. Can you tell me what effect this has on our moods when we do it, Iris? Yeah, so people differ in the degree to which they tend to accept their negative emotions. So some people naturally do something that I had a hard time doing. They encounter negative emotions and they don't judge them as good or bad. Other people have a tendency to do what I did, which is tell themselves, I shouldn't be feeling the way I'm feeling. This is wrong. And what we found is that the less people accept their negative emotions, the more depressive symptoms, the more anxiety symptoms they experience, and the less well-being they have. And this, by the way,
情绪接纳效果的研究。你能告诉我当我们这样做时，这对我们的情绪有什么影响吗？是的，人们在倾向于接纳负面情绪的程度上有所不同。所以有些人自然会做我很难做到的事情。他们遇到负面情绪，不会评判它们是好是坏。另一些人倾向于做我做过的事情，即告诉自己，我不应该有这种感觉。这是错的。我们发现，人们越不接纳他们的负面情绪，他们经历的抑郁症状、焦虑症状就越多，幸福感就越低。顺便说一句，这
tends to be true for men and for women across different ethnic groups. And in that same study, we also wanted to find out why that is. And we tackled that question in two ways. In one study, we brought people into the lab, and we had them ironically give an impromptu speech that people tend to find stressful. It's a really common anxiety. And so we measured how much negative and how much positive emotions they felt. And people who tend to have an accepting mindset responded to the stressful speech with less negative emotion. They on the whole felt a little bit less anxious, a little bit less distraught. And there was another part of the study where we gave people daily diaries. So every day for two weeks we asked them what was the most stressful
往往适用于不同族裔的男性和女性。在同一项研究中，我们还想找出原因。我们通过两种方式解决了这个问题。在一项研究中，我们将人们带到实验室，讽刺的是，让他们进行即兴演讲，人们往往会觉得这很有压力。这是一种非常普遍的焦虑。所以我们测量了他们感受到了多少负面和多少正面情绪。倾向于拥有接纳心态的人对压力演讲的反应是负面情绪较少。他们总体上感到焦虑较少，痛苦较少。研究的另一部分是我们给人们每日日记。所以连续两周，每天我们都问他们今天发生的最有压力的事情是什么，你对它的情绪反应是什么？你感受到了多少悲伤，多少痛苦？但也包括正面情绪。在你一天中最有压力的事件中，你感受到了多少力量，多少希望，多少快乐？我们发现，在每日日记中拥有接纳心态的人报告说，在应对一天中最有压力的事件时，感受到的负面情绪较少。反过来，这种情绪反应解释了为什么六个月后这些人拥有更好的心理健康。所以这些应对日常逆境的日常情绪似乎是一个非常重要的活性成分，
thing that happened to you today and what were your emotional responses to that? How much sadness, how much distress did you feel? But also positive emotions. How much strength, how much hope, how much joy did you feel during your day's most stressful event? And what we found was that people who have a accepting mindset in their daily diaries reported feeling less negative emotions in response to the day's most stressful events. And in turn, that emotional response explained why six months later those same people had better mental health. So these sort of daily emotions in response to daily adversity seem to be a really important active ingredient
在那种联系中。你知道，当我听到这些想法和研究时，我不禁反思，在世界各地，可能几个世纪以来，一直有哲学、宗教和精神传统在谈论同样的想法，即你应该真正接纳你的情绪，接受它们本来的样子。你不应该过度陷入这些情绪中。你有时会反思这样一个事实吗：你作为21世纪心理学家的工作在某些方面正在映射
in that link. You know, as I'm listening to this, to these ideas and this research, I can't help but reflect on the fact that there have been philosophical and religious and spiritual traditions going back probably many centuries around the world that have talked about the same ideas, the ideas that you should actually accept your emotions for what they are. You shouldn't get overly caught up in those emotions. Do you sometimes reflect on the fact that your work as a psychologist in the 21st century in some ways is mirroring the
古代学者和圣贤的工作？是的，绝对。许多这些想法在世界宗教和哲学中都有先驱。而这些想法最大的代表当然是佛教。佛教是正念的先驱，接纳是正念大哲学中非常重要的一部分。所以，对佛教学者以及佛教修行者和正念研究者有着巨大的知识债务。你知道，我想知道这个
work of you know ancient scholars and sages? Yes, absolutely. So many of those ideas have precursors in world religions and philosophies. And one of the biggest representation of that idea is Buddhism, of course. And Buddhism is the precursor to mindfulness and acceptance is a really big part of the larger philosophy of mindfulness. And so there's a huge intellectual debt owed to Buddhist scholars as well as Buddhist practitioners and researchers on mindfulness. You know, I'm wondering whether this idea
情绪接纳的想法对美国人来说是否特别难以接受。我认为许多美国人可能会将接纳与顺从或失败等想法联系起来。我想知道你的研究参与者是否曾经报告过这一点，Iris？这是一个很好的问题，我们非常关注，因为我们不希望人们接纳糟糕、不公正的
of emotional acceptance might be especially hard to accept for Americans. Many Americans, I think, might associate acceptance with ideas like resignation or defeat. I'm wondering whether your participants in your studies ever report that, Iris? That's a great question that we are really concerned about because we wouldn't want people to accept bad unjust
对于美国人来说，情感接纳可能特别难以接受。我认为许多美国人可能会将接纳与听天由命或失败等观念联系在一起。艾丽丝，我想知道你的研究参与者是否曾提到过这一点？这是一个非常好的问题，我们确实对此感到担忧，因为我们不希望人们去接纳那些糟糕且不公正的事情。
situations, even if it helps them feel better. And so in the research, we also asked participants about their tendency to accept bad situations in addition to their tendency to accept their own emotions and their own negative thoughts. And this is really important because these beneficial effects of accepting your own emotions and thoughts were connected with better mental health while accepting bad situations was not. So it's a separate thing and accepting how you feel does not mean accepting and resigning yourself to bad situations. So in other words, I might feel badly about something and I can accept that I'm feeling
情况，即使这能让他们感觉好受些。因此在研究中，我们除了询问参与者接受自身情绪和负面想法的倾向外，还询问了他们接受糟糕情况的倾向。这一点非常重要，因为接受自身情绪和想法所带来的益处与更好的心理健康有关，而接受糟糕的情况则不然。所以这是两码事，接受自己的感受并不意味着接受并屈从于糟糕的情况。换句话说，我可能对某事感到难过，我可以接受我正在感到
badly about something, but that doesn't necessarily mean I'm turning a blind eye to the thing that's actually making me feel bad. Yes, exactly. And I think actually it might help people in a way to address bad things in their lives. Because if you look your negative feelings in the eye and don't get overwhelmed by them, that might help you more effectively deal with addressing bad, unjust, stressful situations. Do people ever share the worry with you that accepting negative emotions means that those negative emotions are now going to stick around forever? I think it's a really common worry and it explains something that's a little bit of a mystery
对某事感到难过，但这并不一定意味着我对真正让我难过的事情视而不见。是的，完全正确。而且我认为这实际上可能在某种程度上帮助人们处理生活中的糟糕事情。因为如果你直面负面情绪而不被它们淹没，这可能会帮助你更有效地处理糟糕、不公正、充满压力的状况。人们是否曾向你表达过这样的担忧：接受负面情绪意味着这些负面情绪现在会永远挥之不去？我认为这是一个非常普遍的担忧，它解释了一个小小的谜团
which is acceptance sounds really easy, right? You literally don't do anything. You have your emotions, they're there. You don't try to control them, you don't spring into action. So it sounds incredibly easy and yet we have a really, really hard time doing that. Even I myself, I've seen the benefits so often. I still, my first instinct is often to, ooh, bad, make it go away quick. And I think the underlying belief is that
那就是接受听起来很容易，对吧？你实际上什么都不用做。你有你的情绪，它们就在那里。你不试图控制它们，也不急于采取行动。所以这听起来极其简单，但我们却很难做到。即使是我自己，虽然我经常看到其中的好处，但我的第一直觉往往还是：噢，糟糕，快让它消失。我认为其潜在的信念是
I'm going to get overwhelmed by it. And so I need to clamp down on it quickly. So I think it's a really deeply ingrained belief that many of us have and it explains why we don't naturally embrace acceptance. We don't do it all the time. So we've been talking about the importance of accepting feelings of unhappiness, negative emotions, but we started this conversation talking about the problem with chasing happiness. You mentioned earlier that having high expectations for happiness can be a prescription for disappointment.
我会被它淹没。所以我需要迅速压制它。所以我认为这是一种根深蒂固的信念，我们许多人都有这种信念，这也解释了为什么我们不会自然而然地拥抱接受。我们并不能一直这样做。所以我们一直在谈论接受不快乐的感觉、负面情绪的重要性，但我们开始这段对话时谈到的是追求幸福的问题。你之前提到，对幸福抱有高期望可能是导致失望的处方。
What should we do instead, Iris? I think one overall recommendation is to have an accepting mindset for both our negative and our positive emotions. Don't monitor as much, don't try to avoid, don't try to strive too much for something else. One way to think about this is that it kind of replaces a mindset of I need to be with a mindset of I prefer. So I think we can still have preferences. The problems come in where we tell ourselves, I must feel a certain way or else I can't have a good life. That's I think what we need to avoid. So preferences with a light touch are good for our mental health and well-being. It's the need and the concern that we want to get away from.
我们该怎么做呢，艾丽丝？我认为一个总体的建议是，对我们的负面和正面情绪都保持一种接纳的心态。不要过度监控，不要试图回避，不要试图过度追求其他东西。思考这个问题的一种方式是，它将“我必须”的心态替换为“我倾向于”的心态。所以我认为我们仍然可以有偏好。问题在于我们告诉自己：我必须有某种感觉，否则我就不能拥有美好的生活。我认为这正是我们需要避免的。所以，带着轻松心态的偏好对我们的心理健康和幸福是有益的。我们想要摆脱的是那种“需要”和“担忧”。
So if you could take this insight back to when you were setting up that birthday party for your son in a park as it's raining, what would you tell yourself in that moment, Iris. What would you advise that Iris today? I would tell myself that it's okay to prefer to have a wonderful birthday party, but that I don't need it to be the perfect birthday party where all the kids are completely happy 100% of the time, and that my son and my life and all the important things are going to be okay, even if it's not. You know, I'm thinking about the fact, Iris, that there are so many books and podcasts and blogs about how to be happier, and in some ways they constitute something of a happiness industrial complex.
所以，如果你能把这个见解带回到你儿子在公园过生日却下雨的时候，那一刻你会对自己说什么，艾丽丝？你会给今天的艾丽丝什么建议？我会告诉自己，倾向于举办一场精彩的生日派对是可以的，但我不需要它成为一场完美的生日派对，不需要所有的孩子在百分之百的时间里都完全快乐，而且即使不是这样，我儿子、我的生活以及所有重要的事情也都会好起来的。你知道，我在想，艾丽丝，有那么多关于如何变得更快乐的书籍、播客和博客，在某种程度上，它们构成了一种“幸福工业综合体”。
This industry tells us that we need to work hard at being happy, and in so many ways, it sounds like you're saying we need to do exactly the opposite. Yes. saying we need to do exactly the opposite. Yes, I would say that feeling joy, feeling happiness, is a universal human preference. So I'm not saying we should get rid of all of those books and all of the advice, but I do think we need to fine tune a little bit just how single-mindedly we go about the pursuit, as well as how we go about that pursuit. So connecting with other people, engaging in experiences over
这个行业告诉我们，我们需要努力变得快乐，而在很多方面，听起来你是在说我们需要做完全相反的事情。是的。说我们需要做完全相反的事情。是的，我会说感受快乐、感受幸福是人类普遍的偏好。所以我并不是说我们应该扔掉所有那些书和建议，但我确实认为我们需要微调一下我们追求幸福的专注程度，以及我们追求幸福的方式。所以，与他人建立联系，参与体验而不是
material goods, those are things that tend to work. So I'm wondering Iris, after studying the power of acceptance, both when it comes to dealing with unhappiness as well as when it comes to dealing with happiness, has this changed your own life? Do you find yourself in moments being able to tell yourself not to judge your negative or positive emotions,
物质商品，这些往往是有效的。所以我很好奇，艾丽丝，在研究了接纳的力量之后，无论是在处理不快乐还是在处理幸福方面，这是否改变了你自己的生活？你是否发现自己在某些时刻能够告诉自己不要评判你的负面或正面情绪，
but just to accept them? It's actually pretty difficult to do, at least for me, because the way we encounter happiness, the way we encounter positive and negative emotions, is really deeply ingrained in our upbringing and in our culture. So these are deeply ingrained habits our upbringing and in our culture. So these are deeply ingrained habits of the mind.
而是仅仅去接受它们？这实际上很难做到，至少对我来说是这样，因为我们接触幸福、接触正面和负面情绪的方式，在我们的成长过程和文化中是根深蒂固的。所以这些是根深蒂固的思维习惯。
And so even though it's literally doing nothing, not judging, not trying to control, it can be really difficult for people to do it. But I absolutely try to do it. And one example where I feel like I succeeded is when I reconnected with my childhood friend after a really long time. She actually had gone through cancer and had surgery and chemotherapy. She was in recovery, but still seeing her physically, it was difficult. And there were many feelings of sadness and grief for seeing what she had to go through, the toll it
所以即使这实际上什么都不做，不评判，不试图控制，人们也很难做到。但我绝对会尝试去做。我感觉自己成功的一个例子是，在很长一段时间后，我与儿时的朋友重新取得了联系。她实际上经历过癌症，做过手术和化疗。她正在康复中，但亲眼看到她，还是很困难。看到她所经历的一切，以及这对她的身体造成的伤害，我心中充满了悲伤和痛苦。
had taken on her body. And I think I managed to stay with those feelings because I was able to see how the journey of going through cancer, it's a normal reaction, it's part of life. And what it feels like is almost like watching clouds in the sky or watching a peaceful river go by, right? Where you don't try to control the clouds, you don't try to control the water, you don't judge the clouds or the water. And by doing that, viewing your own emotions as, well, like a river that is just flowing by or through you, we're able to accept what it is and let it the University of California, Berkeley. Iris, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It was so lovely to talk with you.
但我认为我成功地留在了那些感受中，因为我能够看到，经历癌症的旅程是一种正常的反应，它是生活的一部分。这种感觉就像看着天上的云或看着平静的河流流过，对吧？你不试图控制云，不试图控制水，也不评判云或水。通过这样做，将你自己的情绪视为一条正在流过你或穿过你的河流，我们就能够接受它的本来面目，并让它加州大学伯克利分校。艾丽丝，非常感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。和你交谈真是太愉快了。
Thank you so much. After the break, a conversation about conversations. In the latest edition of our segment, Your Questions Answered, we'll hear listener thoughts on how to have more dynamic discussions with the people around us. Plus, we'll consider whether there's anything we can do to help other people improve their conversational game. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
非常感谢。休息之后，我们将进行一场关于对话的对话。在我们“回答你的问题”环节的最新一期中，我们将听到听众关于如何与周围的人进行更具活力的讨论的想法。此外，我们还将探讨是否有任何方法可以帮助他人提高他们的对话水平。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. When was the last time you had a good catch up with a friend or partner? The kind of chat where you both lost track of time. You told each other stories, reflected on favorite memories. Of course, not all interactions go so smoothly. We've all had conversations that were one-sided, or so disjointed we were left wondering what just happened? Behavioral scientist Alison Woodbrooks studies the science of conversation. She's the author of Talk, the Science of Conversation and the Art of Being
这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。你上一次与朋友或伴侣进行愉快的叙旧是什么时候？那种你们都忘了时间流逝的聊天。你们互相讲述故事，回顾最美好的回忆。当然，并非所有的互动都那么顺利。我们都经历过那种单方面的，或者语无伦次到让我们怀疑刚才发生了什么的对话。行为科学家艾莉森·伍德布鲁克斯研究对话科学。她是《谈话：对话的科学与做自己的艺术》一书的作者。
Ourselves. In this edition of Your Questions Answered, we've asked Allison to come back to answer your questions on how to have better conversations. If you missed our earlier episodes with Allison, you can find them in this podcast feed. The first is called We Need to Talk. The second is titled The Conversations That Bring Us Closer. Allison Woodbrooks, welcome back to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me back. Allison, you cite the professional matchmaker, Rachel Greenwald.
在这一期的“回答你的问题”中，我们请艾莉森回来回答你们关于如何进行更好对话的问题。如果你错过了我们之前与艾莉森的节目，你可以在这个播客订阅源中找到它们。第一期叫《我们需要谈谈》。第二期标题是《让我们更亲近的对话》。艾莉森·伍德布鲁克斯，欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我回来。艾莉森，你引用了专业媒人瑞秋·格林沃尔德的话。
She talks about something she calls the mood elevator in conversations. What is the mood elevator? The mood elevator is this idea that you, throughout a conversation, are moving up and down in terms of mood. As a scholar, we think about emotions, actually, as more complex than just good or bad or moving up and down. But it is a really nice idea to keep in mind
她谈到了一种她在对话中称之为“情绪电梯”的东西。什么是情绪电梯？情绪电梯是一个概念，即在整个对话过程中，你的情绪会上下波动。作为一名学者，我们认为情绪实际上比仅仅是好或坏，或者上下波动要复杂得多。但记住这一点确实是一个很好的想法
what the sort of temperature or emotional timbre of the conversation is as it proceeds. And good conversationalists are good at sort of keeping their hand on the steering wheel, realizing when things have gotten too boring and dull, and also realizing when maybe things are getting too heated, too angry, too hostile, and actually making moves to try and keep the mood elevator moving in the right direction. Alison, we rarely consider a conversation's purpose before starting it. Few of us sit down and say, okay, this is my goal, this is my agenda, my vision for the conversation. You argue that this can make conversations worse. How so?
对话进行时的温度或情绪基调是什么样的。优秀的对话者善于掌控方向盘，意识到事情何时变得太无聊和沉闷，也意识到事情何时可能变得太激烈、太愤怒、太敌对，并实际上采取行动试图让情绪电梯朝着正确的方向移动。艾莉森，我们在开始对话之前很少考虑对话的目的。我们很少有人坐下来会说，好吧，这是我的目标，这是我的议程，我对这次对话的愿景。你认为这会让对话变得更糟。怎么会呢？
That's right. The very meaning of what success is in conversation depends on what the speakers want to get out of it, what their goals are, what their sincere desires are. And so often most of the time we go into conversations, not having a clue what our goals are. Uh, maybe you loosely know, oh, I want to spend time with someone and I don't want it to be awkward. But having just a little bit more clarity about what you want out of the conversation, and maybe even more importantly, what your partner wants out of the conversation,
没错。对话成功的真正含义取决于说话者想从中得到什么，他们的目标是什么，他们真诚的愿望是什么。所以大多数时候，我们进入对话时，根本不知道自己的目标是什么。呃，也许你模糊地知道，哦，我想和某人共度时光，我不希望这很尴尬。但对你从对话中想要什么有更清晰的认识，甚至更重要的是，你的伙伴从对话中想要什么，
is the key to figuring out what success even looks like. For example, if you need to learn something about the other person or about a specific topic, you better ask and move to that topic. And if you don't, that's a signal of sort of conversational failure in a way. Our goals are not always serious and sort of productivity driven.
是弄清楚成功到底是什么样子的关键。例如，如果你需要了解对方或某个特定主题的信息，你最好询问并转向那个主题。如果你不这样做，这在某种程度上是一种对话失败的信号。我们的目标并不总是严肃和以生产力为导向的。
Often our goals are just to have fun together or fill time, learn about each other, but those are important motives. And so even knowing that, hey, I just wanna spend these 30 minutes with this person and I wanna laugh. Knowing that should guide what choices you make during that interaction. Do you actually recommend that people talk to one another
通常我们的目标只是为了在一起玩得开心或打发时间，了解彼此，但这些都是重要的动机。所以即使知道这一点，嘿，我只是想和这个人共度这30分钟，我想笑。知道这一点应该指导你在互动过程中做出什么选择。你真的建议人们在开始对话之前
before they start a conversation saying, here's's the headspace I'm in here's what I'm hoping to get out of it? I think the clearer we can be with others about what we care about and what we want the more likely those people are to actually fulfill those needs. We know that people aren't we're not that great at guessing what other people want and you see this happen a lot with like married couples who get mad at each other because you're they're like you know I don't need you that great at guessing what other people want. And you see this happen a lot with married couples who get mad at each other because they're like, I don't need you to solve my problem.
互相交谈，说，这是我现在的心理状态，这是我希望从中得到的吗？我认为我们对他人在意什么和想要什么表达得越清楚，这些人就越有可能真正满足这些需求。我们知道人们并不擅长猜测别人想要什么，你在已婚夫妇身上经常看到这种情况，他们因为对方而生气，因为他们觉得……你不需要你擅长猜测别人想要什么。你在已婚夫妇身上经常看到这种情况，他们因为对方而生气，因为他们觉得，我不需要你解决我的问题。
I just need a hug. But part of that responsibility is you can literally say, I just need someone to listen, or I just need a hug right now. I actually don't need you to solve this problem before they do the wrong thing. But of course, it's also, it's complicated because stating your goals explicitly can also undermine them.
我只是需要一个拥抱。但这种责任的一部分是，你可以直说，我只是需要有人倾听，或者我现在只是需要一个拥抱。在他们做错事之前，我其实并不需要你解决这个问题。但当然，这也很复杂，因为明确陈述你的目标也可能破坏它们。
If I say like, oh, I just really wanna laugh a lot, I'm not sure that's the right pathway to actually laughing a lot with each other. So it is a little complicated. Yeah. Let's move on to the listener questions. We received a number of questions from people who feel like their conversations are imbalanced. Here's Dave. I tend to be someone who is very interested in other
如果我说，哦，我真的想多笑笑，我不确定这是真正互相大笑的正确途径。所以这确实有点复杂。是的。让我们进入听众提问环节。我们收到了许多觉得对话不平衡的人提出的问题。这是戴夫。我倾向于是一个对他人非常感兴趣的人，
people, so I ask a lot of questions. The problem is it's relatively rare to encounter someone who reciprocates and asks questions of me. So that most conversations end up being people talking about themselves. So my question is, is it possible to ask too many questions so that you've set a dynamic where the other partner you're conversing with is accustomed to just talking about themselves. Thanks. So we talked in our earlier conversation, Allison, about the superpower that is asking
所以我问了很多问题。问题是，很少遇到会礼尚往来并问我问题的人。所以大多数对话最终都变成了人们谈论他们自己。所以我的问题是，问太多问题是否可能导致你设定了一种动态，即与你交谈的另一方习惯于只谈论他们自己。谢谢。所以我们在之前的对话中谈到了，艾莉森，提问是一种超能力。
questions. And I guess Dave is asking, is this a superpower that can be taken too far? It's a great question, Dave. So yes, of course, we can all probably think of people in our lives who have asked too many questions or who habitually ask too many questions. But asking too many questions is much more rare than not asking enough questions, actually. And actually, sometimes it can happen in predictable contexts. For example, on first dates, we don't see in our research any tipping point for asking too many questions.
我想戴夫是在问，这是一种可以被过度使用的超能力吗？这是一个很好的问题，戴夫。所以是的，我们当然都能想到生活中那些问了太多问题，或者习惯性问太多问题的人。但实际上，问太多问题比问得不够要罕见得多。而且有时它可能发生在可预测的环境中。例如，在第一次约会时，我们在研究中没有看到问太多问题的临界点。
You have so much to learn about each other in that context, and your goals are very aligned. It's a very cooperative task. On the other hand, take for example sales calls, which we've also studied. There is a tipping point for asking too many questions, usually because you're more suspicious of each other's motives or you have colliding purposes. Are they trying to take advantage of me? Are they asking about these questions because they want to learn information only to then exploit me and raise the price or something?
在这种情况下，你们有很多东西需要了解彼此，而且你们的目标非常一致。这是一项非常合作的任务。另一方面，以我们研究过的销售电话为例。问太多问题确实有一个临界点，通常是因为你们对彼此的动机更加怀疑，或者你们有冲突的目的。他们是在试图利用我吗？他们问这些问题是因为他们想了解信息，然后利用我并提高价格或什么的吗？
But even there, asking too many questions turns out to be better than asking too few. And so what we see in our data is that there is a tipping point. So for example, on a huge data set of 30-minute sales calls, there is a tipping point where asking four questions per minute starts to go down in terms of likeability for the other person. But even there, even if you're at that very high end of asking questions, it's better than being at the very low end where you're not asking enough. In some ways, I think that leads us to the next question, which comes from Eduardo. I often feel that in
但即使在那里，问太多问题也比问得太少要好。所以我们在数据中看到的是，确实存在一个临界点。例如，在30分钟销售电话的庞大数据集中，有一个临界点，即每分钟问四个问题开始在对方的好感度方面下降。但即使在那里，即使你处于问问题的最高端，也比处于问得不够的最低端要好。在某种程度上，我认为这引出了下一个问题，来自爱德华多。我经常觉得在
conversations with many people, we all have a shared responsibility to keep it going. And I very often feel that when someone is silent on a corner, just listening is in a way an act of selfishness. The sense that they're not contributing to this conversation and just sitting and listening feels a little unfair to the rest of us. I don't know if I'm alone on this feeling. What do you think? So in some ways this is the flip side of the earlier problem, Alison. Instead of one person, you know, talking a lot about themselves
与许多人的对话中，我们都有共同的责任来维持对话。我经常觉得，当有人在角落里沉默，只是听着，在某种程度上是一种自私的行为。那种他们没有为对话做出贡献，只是坐着听的感觉对我们其他人来说有点不公平。我不知道这种感觉是否只有我一个人有。你怎么看？所以从某种程度上说，这是之前问题的反面，艾莉森。不是一个人，你知道，谈论自己很多
and not asking any questions, one person is silent a lot and that makes Eduardo resentful. Eduardo, I hear you. I think it's a fascinating question of who's responsible. You use the phrase shared responsibility. And it's true because every conversation is sort of jointly constructed by multiple people. Things get much more complicated in groups. We feel like group conversation is the same task as one-on-one conversation because you're
而不问任何问题，而是有一个人沉默很多，这让爱德华多感到怨恨。爱德华多，我听到了。我认为这是一个关于谁负责的迷人问题。你用了“共同责任”这个词。这是真的，因为每一次对话都是由多个人共同构建的。在群体中，事情会变得复杂得多。我们觉得群体对话和一对一对话是一样的任务，因为你
speaking and listening. But actually, as soon as a third person pulls up a chair, it's possible then for one person in the group to say nothing and still be involved in the conversation, still be sort of eavesdropping on the other two. And group conversation is such a coordination kerfuffle that getting these airtime dynamics right is very, very hard. And so I think there are things that Eduardo could do to sort of nudge the quiet person
在说话和倾听。但实际上，一旦第三个人拉过一把椅子，群体中的一个人就有可能什么都不说，但仍然参与对话，仍然在某种程度上窃听另外两个人。群体对话是一种协调上的混乱，要搞定这些发言时间的动态是非常非常困难的。所以我认为爱德华多可以做一些事情来稍微推动安静的人
to participate more. You can make sure that you're making eye contact with quiet members of a group to make sure that they feel seen and included and sort of give them a wink like, hey, I want to hear from you. And that same is true for people who are talking too much. There are things you can do. You can kind of cut them off. You can redirect to another group member and say, you know, what do you think of what they're saying? But at some point, and especially in group conversation, while there is a shared responsibility to create a good experience, there's also lack
更多地参与。你可以确保你与群体中安静的成员进行眼神交流，以确保他们感到被看见和被包容，并给他们一个暗示，比如，嘿，我想听听你的意见。对于那些说得太多的人也是如此。你可以做一些事情。你可以稍微打断他们。你可以转向另一个小组成员说，你知道，你对他们说的话怎么看？但在某种程度上，特别是在群体对话中，虽然有共同的责任来创造良好的体验，但也存在
of control. You don't have control over what people say and do. And so if somebody is there and they're very quiet, you never really know what's going on in their mind. You don't know if they're feeling anxious or shy, they don't feel like they have something to add or they're really enjoying themselves, what you do have control over is your mindset about it and your actions, right? So trying not to come from a place of judgment, negative judgment about it.
缺乏控制。你无法控制人们说什么和做什么。所以如果有人在那里，他们非常安静，你永远不知道他们的脑子里在想什么。你不知道他们是感到焦虑或害羞，觉得没什么可补充的，还是他们真的很享受，你所能控制的是你对此的心态和你的行动，对吧？所以尽量不要从评判的角度，负面的评判出发。
And instead, what you could do is after that group conversation has ended, you could pull that person aside privately and just say like, hey, are you okay? You seem really quiet or was that fun for you? Ask them questions to try and learn their perspective. I like the idea of starting with compassion. We got a note from a listener named Deborah who wrote in to say, I wanted to share that it may not be disinterest
相反，你可以做的是在群体对话结束后，私下把那个人拉到一边说，嘿，你还好吗？你看起来很安静，或者这对你来说有趣吗？问他们问题，试图了解他们的观点。我喜欢从同情心开始的想法。我们收到了一位名叫黛博拉的听众的来信，她说，我想分享的是，这可能不是冷漠
or self-centeredness that keeps someone from asking questions, but fear of appearing nosy or tone deaf or lame. Being at a loss for words doesn't seem like a problem I would ever have. But when it comes to asking questions, my brain absolutely freezes. So I guess it's useful to hear someone like Debra.
或以自我为中心导致某人不问问题，而是害怕显得爱管闲事、不合时宜或笨拙。词穷似乎不是我会有问题。但当涉及到问问题时，我的大脑绝对会冻结。所以我想听到像黛博拉这样的人说话很有用。
Sometimes a silent person is not just free-riding on the conversation, but is petrified about how to enter it. That's right. Silence is often a sign of deference and respect. And it's funny, public rhetoric so much is about like, well, let's empower people to speak up. But often not speaking is a really lovely, very considered choice if you don't feel like you have something to add. Or if you feel like, oh, other people are on a roll and I don't want to interrupt that they're sharing these stories with each other.
有时一个沉默的人不仅仅是在对话中“搭便车”，而是对如何进入对话感到恐惧。没错。沉默往往是谦逊和尊重的标志。有趣的是，公共修辞很大程度上是关于，好吧，让我们赋予人们发言的权力。但通常不说话是一个非常可爱、非常深思熟虑的选择，如果你觉得没什么可补充的话。或者如果你觉得，哦，其他人正在兴头上，我不想打断他们，他们正在互相分享这些故事。
So very often the choice to be quiet is kind and very polite. And you can't really tell the difference. So if someone like Deborah is in a group with Eduardo and Eduardo is feeling annoyed that Deborah is not speaking, the question becomes, how do we get them to communicate with each other about what's going on privately in their minds, where Eduardo is feeling annoyed that Deborah is not talking and Deborah is sort of sitting there feeling like, well, I don't want to ask a question that's rude. So they're both coming from with virtuous motives and sort of need to know that about
所以很多时候，保持安静的选择是善良且非常有礼貌的。你真的无法分辨其中的区别。所以如果像黛博拉这样的人和爱德华多在一个小组里，而爱德华多因为黛博拉不说话而感到恼火，问题就变成了，我们如何让他们互相沟通关于他们私下脑子里在想什么，爱德华多因为黛博拉不说话而感到恼火，而黛博拉坐在那里觉得，好吧，我不想问一个粗鲁的问题。所以他们都出于善良的动机，并且需要知道这一点
each other. So as Deborah pointed out, some people hesitate to ask questions because they're worried about coming across as intrusive. But a listener named Rosalyn wrote in about asking a question and then realizing she had made a blunder. As an adult and understanding the importance of showing interest in others, I asked a new friend if they were renting their house in our neighborhood. My thinking was to find out if they were happy with the neighborhood and wanted to stay permanently. This person pulled me aside and asked me not to ask him that question
关于彼此。所以正如黛博拉指出的那样，有些人因为担心显得爱管闲事而犹豫是否要问问题。但一位名叫罗莎琳的听众写信来讲述了她问了一个问题，然后意识到自己犯了一个错误。作为一个成年人，理解向他人表现出兴趣的重要性，我问了一位新朋友他们是否在我们社区租房。我的想法是想了解他们是否对社区满意，并想永久居住。这个人把我拉到一边，要求我不要问他那个问题
again, especially in front of others. They were offended by my question since the perceived implication was that if they rent, they can't afford to buy, and I had effectively broadcast that to everyone. So talk a moment, Allison, about landmines in conversation. I don't believe that Rosalind was trying to offend, but it looks like she gave offense. That's right. Rosalind, don't beat yourself up. We all do this all the time.
再次询问，特别是在别人面前。他们被我的问题冒犯了，因为隐含的意思是如果他们租房，他们就买不起房，而我实际上已经向所有人广播了这一点。所以谈谈吧，艾莉森，关于对话中的地雷。我不相信罗莎琳是想冒犯，但看起来她确实冒犯了。没错。罗莎琳，别自责。我们所有人一直都在这样做。
I think there is something, an important point here, which is the question itself wasn't offensive. And this is often the case that questions are not offensive. Topics aren't sensitive. But what is sensitive is the context. I wasn't surprised at all in listening to this question that in the middle, Rosalynn said it was in front of other people.
我认为这里有一个重要的点，就是问题本身并不冒犯人。这种情况经常发生，问题并不冒犯人。话题并不敏感。但敏感的是语境。听到这个问题时，我一点也不惊讶，罗莎琳在中间说是在别人面前。
As soon as it's no longer a one-on-one conversation, as soon as a third person pulls up a chair or even more people are there, the potential for shame enters the conversation. So imagine if Rosalind had asked that exact same question, but it had been one-on-one with this friend, it probably would have been fine. And maybe it would have even been a place where they could have become closer. And this friend said, you know, I feel a little embarrassed that I'm not able to buy a house yet. But these small moves in conversation in groups, there's so many more people watching and the potential for judgment that even questions that in another context would not be sensitive can become much more threatening and sort of embarrassing and filled with the potential
一旦它不再是一对一的对话，一旦第三个人拉过一把椅子，或者有更多人在场，羞耻感就会进入对话。所以想象一下，如果罗莎琳问了同样的问题，但那是和这位朋友一对一的，那可能就没问题了。也许那甚至可能是一个他们可以变得更亲近的地方。这位朋友说，你知道，我感到有点尴尬，因为我还买不起房子。但在群体对话中的这些小动作，有更多人在观看，而且存在评判的潜力，以至于即使在其他语境下并不敏感的问题，也会变得更具威胁性，更令人尴尬，并充满潜力
for shame. This is Your Questions Answered, our segment in which we bring researchers back to answer listener questions. After the break, Alison Woodbrookes will answer questions on how to improve conversations with your partner, children, and friends. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Allison Woodbrooks is a behavioral scientist at Harvard Business School. For many years now, she has studied the science of conversation. We featured Allison's work in a series of conversations in February. You can find the links to those conversations in the show notes for today's episode. conversations in the show notes for today's episode.
充满羞耻感。这是《回答你的问题》，我们的环节，我们请研究人员回来回答听众的问题。休息之后，艾莉森·伍德布鲁克斯将回答关于如何改善与伴侣、孩子和朋友的对话的问题。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。艾莉森·伍德布鲁克斯是哈佛商学院的行为科学家。多年来，她一直研究对话科学。我们在二月份的一系列对话中介绍了艾莉森的工作。你可以在今天节目的节目说明中找到这些对话的链接。
Allison, in our original conversation you taught me the term ZQ which refers to someone who is a zero-questioner. Now typically ZQers show up on first or second dates, but they can also show up in other parts of our lives as well. Here's listener Gene wondering how to navigate ZQs in friendships. I'm going to have lunch tomorrow with two friends I've known for 60 years. Both are ZQs, but they are far from the only ones. Most everyone I'm around is a ZQ. Nearly all of my friends and acquaintances are ZQs. I'm always the one asking questions. I'm always the one asking follow-up questions. I'm the one who brings an agenda to a conversation.
艾莉森，在我们最初的对话中，你教了我“ZQ”这个词，指的是“零提问者”。现在，通常ZQ者出现在第一次或第二次约会中，但他们也可能出现在我们生活的其他部分。这是听众吉恩想知道如何处理友谊中的ZQ者。我明天要和两个认识60年的朋友吃午饭。两人都是ZQ者，但他们远非仅有的。我周围的大多数人都是ZQ者。我所有的朋友和熟人几乎都是ZQ者。我总是那个问问题的人。我总是那个问后续问题的人。我是那个给对话带来议程的人。
Do I need to ditch these friends and acquaintances and get new ones? What do you think, Allison? Oh, Gene, it's such a great question. I think many people feel this way about certain people in their lives. It's one that I keep in mind too. Conversation is a place that profoundly makes us reflect about what we have control over and what we don't have control over. Ultimately, you can't force other people to ask you questions. At the beginning of a relationship, I think, let's say in dating, it's a legitimate reason to say, you know what, maybe I don't want to go on a second date with this person.
我需要甩掉这些朋友和熟人，结交新朋友吗？你怎么看，艾莉森？哦，吉恩，这是一个很好的问题。我想许多人对他们生活中的某些人也有这种感觉。这也是我一直记在心里的一个问题。对话是一个深刻地让我们反思我们能控制什么，不能控制什么的地方。最终，你不能强迫别人问你问题。在一段关系的开始，我想，比如在约会中，说“你知道吗，也许我不想和这个人进行第二次约会”是一个合理的理由。
But once you're in a long-term friendship or a long-term relationship and that friend or your romantic partner, if it's really bothering you that they're not showing more curiosity or interest about your life or they're not asking questions or maybe it's bugging you that they're not asking questions to other people and you have to sort of suffer through their habits, observing their habits and you feel embarrassed. I do think if you're in a good sturdy trusting relationship, this is the kind of thing you could think about giving them feedback about. That is a big if, right? Like you need to be in a really positive, trusting, loving place to be able to say, you know what, I would really love for you to ask me more questions.
但一旦你处于长期的友谊或长期的关系中，那个朋友或你的浪漫伴侣，如果他们没有表现出更多的好奇心或对你的生活感兴趣，或者他们不问问题，这真的让你很困扰，或者也许让你困扰的是他们不问别人问题，你不得不忍受他们的习惯，观察他们的习惯，你感到尴尬。我确实认为，如果你处于一段良好、稳固、信任的关系中，这是你可以考虑给他们反馈的事情。这是一个很大的“如果”，对吧？你需要处于一个非常积极、信任、充满爱的地方，才能说，你知道吗，我真的希望你多问我一些问题。
And you might learn something really great. They might say, oh, I don't because I always worry that it's too nosy or I know that you don't love talking about yourself, which is why I don't ask. That's the kind of brave conversational thing that might unearth new information even in an old long-term friendship or relationship. You know, when Gene says that he's known these two friends for 60 years, in my mind I'm thinking, well, you should tell them. Maybe you should be asking me more questions.
而且你可能会学到一些非常棒的东西。他们可能会说，哦，我不问是因为我总是担心这太爱管闲事了，或者我知道你不喜欢谈论你自己，这就是我不问的原因。这是一种勇敢的对话行为，即使在长期的友谊或关系中，也可能挖掘出新的信息。你知道，当吉恩说他认识这两个朋友60年时，我心里想，好吧，你应该告诉他们。也许你应该多问我一些问题。
But I realize as I say that, that I'm feeling hypocritical because I'm thinking, well, you should tell them, you know, maybe you should be asking me more questions. But I realize as I say that, that I'm feeling hypocritical because I'm thinking about somebody whom I've known for a long time, who never asks any questions in conversations. And after some time I'm finding that, you know, I try and avoid this person. I don't look forward to actually, you know, hanging out with this person, but I haven't had the courage to actually tell them, you know, here's why I think, you know, you should be asking more questions. In an interesting way, it's a fascinating test of
但我意识到当我这么说时，我感到虚伪，因为我在想，好吧，你应该告诉他们，你知道，也许你应该多问我一些问题。但我意识到当我这么说时，我感到虚伪，因为我在想一个我认识很久的人，他在对话中从不问任何问题。过了一段时间，我发现，你知道，我尽量避免这个人。我不期待，你知道，和这个人在一起，但我没有勇气真正告诉他们，你知道，这就是为什么我认为，你知道，你应该多问一些问题。以一种有趣的方式，这是一个迷人的测试
how much do you value that relationship? Because I think over time, these are the sort of small things that accumulate that do push us apart or can bring us closer. And this sort of decision of do I give this feedback or not is a test of, well, what do you want this person to be in your life going forward? How much can you tolerate?
你有多重视那段关系？因为我认为随着时间的推移，这些都是积累起来的小事，确实会把我们推开，或者能让我们更亲近。这种“我是否给出这个反馈”的决定，是对“你希望这个人未来在你生活中扮演什么角色”的测试。你能容忍多少？
Yeah. Another issue that bothered a lot of listeners was the topic of interruptions. Here's Dwight. I find myself being interrupted several times, most frequently by my close family. How do I stop that from happening or draw their attention to the fact that I don't appreciate it? This is a topic very near and dear to my heart, Dwight.
是的。另一个困扰许多听众的问题是打断的话题。这是德怀特。我发现自己被多次打断，最频繁的是我的亲密家人。我该如何阻止这种情况发生，或者引起他们注意我不喜欢这一点？这是一个非常贴近我心的话题，德怀特。
I hear you. I want to draw a distinction that I think you might my heart, Dwight. I hear you. I want to draw a distinction that I think you might find helpful, Dwight, and I hope others do too. Interruptions come in two flavors. One is when someone cuts you off and stays on the same topic, versus they cut you off and they jump cut to something unrelated. On-topic interruptions are actually pretty great.
我听到了。我想划定一个我认为你可能会觉得有帮助的界限，德怀特，我希望其他人也觉得有帮助。打断有两种风格。一种是有人打断你并停留在同一个话题上，另一种是他们打断你并跳到不相关的事情上。话题内的打断实际上相当不错。
It's a sign that the person you're talking to is very engaged and they're listening and they're so excited about where you're going that they can't wait for you to finish your sentence or your statement. It still can be annoying, right? They're still cutting you off so you can't finish your thought, but it is a sign that you are connecting and that you have this bubbling back and forth. On the other hand, off-topic interruptions are the kind that we think of, you know, the jerk who cuts someone off and changes the subject because they're not interested. That is actually quite rude and very frustrating. So I would nudge you Dwight to think about which type is happening to you. And if it's the positive flavor, the
这是一个信号，表明你正在交谈的人非常投入，他们在倾听，他们对你要去的地方感到非常兴奋，以至于他们等不及你完成你的句子或陈述。这仍然可能很烦人，对吧？他们仍然在打断你，所以你无法完成你的想法，但这确实是一个信号，表明你们正在建立联系，并且你们有这种活跃的来回。另一方面，话题外的打断是我们想到的那种，你知道，打断别人并改变话题的混蛋，因为他们不感兴趣。这实际上相当粗鲁且非常令人沮丧。所以我建议你，德怀特，考虑一下发生在你身上的是哪种类型。如果是积极的风格，
on-topic interruption, maybe to try to just feel, foster a little bit more gratitude, sort of do the reframe of like, oh yeah, this is happening because they love me or they care so much about what we're talking about, they can't possibly wait for me to finish. Or if it's the sort of bad kind where someone is truly not interested in what you're saying and is shifting to something else, then that's a situation where you might think about giving them feedback. Like, hey, it actually makes me feel not only annoyed, but probably a little hurt that you're constantly switching the conversation away from me and my ideas.
话题内的打断，也许试着去感受，培养多一点感激之情，进行一种重构，比如，哦，是的，这发生是因为他们爱我，或者他们非常关心我们正在谈论的事情，他们不可能等我完成。或者如果是那种坏的，有人真的对你说的话不感兴趣，并转向其他事情，那么这就是你可能考虑给他们反馈的情况。比如，嘿，你不断地把对话从我和我的想法上转移开，这不仅让我感到恼火，可能还让我感到有点受伤。
Just wanted to let you know that's how I'm feeling. And if it's people who are really close to you, they should care. They should take that seriously. We got an interesting note from a listener Kate who in some ways raises a new dimension of interruptions that I think has to do with the timing of when people enter conversations. Here's Kate. I often seem to misjudge conversational pauses and find myself interrupting someone who has simply taken a breath not finished their thought.
只是想让你知道这就是我的感受。如果他们是和你非常亲近的人，他们应该关心。他们应该认真对待。我们收到了一位名叫凯特的听众的有趣来信，她在某种程度上提出了打断的一个新维度，我认为这与人们进入对话的时间有关。这是凯特。我似乎经常误判对话的停顿，发现自己打断了一个只是吸了口气，并没有完成想法的人。
I tell myself it might be because I grew up in the UK and conversational pace is probably different in different cultures, but I suspect that's just an excuse. How can we tell when it's our turn to speak? What do you think, Alison? Because in some ways this is actually a profound problem. As you've pointed out, you know, there's no in some ways this is actually a profound problem, as you've pointed out. You know, there's no conductor for the orchestra of a conversation, no conductor who says, you know, now it's time for the string section to come in and now it's time for the violins
我告诉自己这可能是因为我在英国长大，对话节奏在不同文化中可能不同，但我怀疑那只是借口。我们怎么能知道什么时候轮到我们说话？你怎么看，艾莉森？因为在某种程度上，这实际上是一个深刻的问题。正如你指出的，你知道，没有指挥家来指挥对话的管弦乐队，没有指挥家说，你知道，现在是弦乐部分进来的时候了，现在是小提琴
to quiet down just a bit. There's no one organizing the conversation, so people have to guess when someone is done talking before they can jump in. What if we all have different estimations of when someone has finished? It's a great question. I think this is part of what it means to get close with certain people
安静一点的时候了。没有人组织对话，所以人们必须在别人说完话之前猜测什么时候可以跳进去。如果我们对别人什么时候说完都有不同的估计怎么办？这是一个很好的问题。我认为这是与某些人变得亲近的意义的一部分
or to become familiar with a certain culture. This is part of that cultural learning or that sort of relational learning is learning people's preferences about how long should we wait before the next person talks. cultural learning or that sort of relational learning is learning people's preferences about how long should we wait before the next person talks? How acceptable is it for me to cut people off or to jump in before they're done? And it can be a cultural thing, but it also can just be part of your shared reality in a relationship where you develop your own norms and equilibrium of what's acceptable. But I think someone like this who's feeling like, oh, maybe I'm jumping in too soon,
或者熟悉某种文化。这是文化学习或关系学习的一部分，即学习人们关于在下一个人说话之前我们应该等待多长时间的偏好。我打断别人或在他们说完之前跳进去的接受度有多高？这可能是一种文化现象，但也可能只是你们关系中共享现实的一部分，你们发展出自己的规范和什么是可接受的平衡。但我认为像这样觉得“哦，也许我跳进去太快了”的人，
it's the kind of thing that you could work on and just say, oh, I'm gonna try it today or in this conversation to be a little bit more patient. I wanna make sure I let my partner finish all the way before I jump in and do it as a little test for yourself. I constantly do this kind of test for myself and I find it quite helpful. Catherine wrote to us about her situation. She is more of a fast-paced
这是你可以努力的事情，只要说，哦，我今天或在这次对话中要尝试多一点耐心。我想确保我让我的伙伴完全说完，然后再跳进去，把它当作你自己的一个小测试。我经常为自己做这种测试，我觉得它非常有帮助。凯瑟琳写信给我们讲述了她的情况。她是一个快节奏的人
talker. She likes a lot of back and forth. Her boyfriend enjoys having a little more space in conversations and he likes time to consider his responses. Here's Catherine describing their interactions. I'm wondering for those people who have that different type of conversational style, if they sometimes feel a little bit lost or a little swept along by those of us who like that more rapid fire, sometimes even talking over each other's style, is there any advice that you could offer for someone who maybe needs a little more time to process a conversation before responding? In other words, can fast talkers and slow talkers get along, Allison? I sure hope so.
谈话者。她喜欢有很多来回的互动。她的男朋友在谈话中喜欢多一点空间，也喜欢有时间去思考他的回应。这是凯瑟琳对他们互动方式的描述。我想知道，对于那些有不同谈话风格的人来说，他们是否有时会感到有点迷茫，或者被我们这些喜欢快节奏、有时甚至会打断对方说话的人所裹挟？对于那些在回应前可能需要更多时间来处理谈话内容的人，你有什么建议吗？换句话说，艾莉森，快语速的人和慢语速的人能相处得来吗？我当然希望如此。
That's it. Catherine, I very much resonate with this in my own marriage. I think yes, but I think having awareness of your own style and other style is a huge part of being good communicators, right? So being a kind of conversationalist means understanding your partner's needs and preferences, no matter what your needs and preferences are, and trying to relentlessly focus on what they need and trying to fulfill it. So if you're a fast talker like Catherine and you feel like the conversation is moving
就是这样。凯瑟琳，我在自己的婚姻中对此深有共鸣。我认为可以，但我认为意识到自己的风格和他人的风格是成为优秀沟通者的重要部分，对吧？所以，成为一个好的谈话者意味着理解你伴侣的需求和偏好，无论你自己的需求和偏好是什么，并努力不懈地关注他们需要什么，并试图去满足它。所以，如果你像凯瑟琳一样是个快语速的人，而你觉得谈话进行得
too quickly and it's starting to annoy your partner or they're feeling lost or they need more space, then slowing down, pulling back during the conversation can be an act of kindness or even suggesting, hey, let's take a little break. You think about this for a little bit. I'm going to go grab a drink or a glass of water and then I'll come back and we'll pick it back up. You can give gifts like that of spaciousness or even just asking question of like, am I moving too fast? I realize I'm like getting too excited right now.
太快了，开始让你的伴侣感到烦恼，或者他们感到迷茫，或者他们需要更多的空间，那么在谈话中放慢速度、退后一步可以是一种善意的表现，甚至可以建议说：“嘿，我们休息一下吧。你先思考一会儿。我去拿杯饮料或喝点水，然后再回来继续。”你可以给予像这样留出空间的礼物，或者仅仅是问一个问题，比如：“我是不是说得太快了？我意识到我现在太兴奋了。”
What do you need from me? And the same is true in the opposite direction. So Catherine's partner can do this reframe of like, I know I can get lost or get annoyed with you moving so quickly, but that's part of what makes you special and exciting and fun to talk to. So the responsibility is also in his court to say, hey, maybe let's slow down, maybe let's take a break or just say like, hey, I really appreciate the high energy, but let's take a little breath here. After the break, Alison Woodbrooks will answer more of your questions on how to improve conversations.
你需要我做什么？反过来也是一样。所以凯瑟琳的伴侣可以换个角度思考，比如：“我知道当你说话这么快时，我可能会感到迷茫或烦躁，但这正是你特别、令人兴奋且谈话有趣的原因之一。”所以，责任也在他这一边，可以说：“嘿，也许我们慢一点，也许我们休息一下，或者只是说，嘿，我真的很欣赏这种高能量，但让我们在这里喘口气。”休息之后，艾莉森·伍德·布鲁克斯将回答更多关于如何改善谈话的问题。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Good conversations often feel effortless, where in sync with someone, the jokes and laughter are flowing, and we feel happy and engaged. Many conversations, however, are not effortless. They feel awkward, stilted or upsetting. Behavioral scientist Alison Woodbrooke studies the science of conversation. She's the author of Talk, the Science of Conversation and the art of being ourselves.
你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。好的谈话通常感觉毫不费力，我们与某人同步，笑话和笑声不断，我们感到快乐和投入。然而，许多谈话并非毫不费力。它们感觉尴尬、生硬或令人不安。行为科学家艾莉森·伍德·布鲁克斯研究谈话的科学。她是《谈话：谈话的科学与做自己的艺术》一书的作者。
Alison, we had some listeners write in about the effects of personality on conversation. Here's a note from Nancy. If you interrogate someone, especially an introvert, with numerous questions without pause, they're going to become passive. Allowing space for a comfortable pause seems like an important part of conversation. How can we learn to be comfortable in the necessary silences of conversation without leaving the conversation? To broaden out Nancy's question a little bit, Allison, can you talk a moment about personality differences and how they affect conversational styles?
艾莉森，我们有一些听众写信询问个性对谈话的影响。这是南希的一条留言：“如果你审问某人，尤其是内向者，在没有停顿的情况下提出无数问题，他们会变得被动。留出舒适的停顿空间似乎是谈话的重要组成部分。我们如何学会在谈话中必要的沉默中感到舒适，而不离开谈话？”为了稍微扩展一下南希的问题，艾莉森，你能谈谈个性差异以及它们如何影响谈话风格吗？
Absolutely. I think, you know, differences, but there are so many people in the world and everyone is incredibly different. And we have a tendency to think a lot about how does my, how do my personality traits affect my behavior and conversation? What are my strengths and weaknesses? I think these reflections can be very productive. And one of the ways that they manifest in conversation is for very different. And one of the ways that they manifest in conversation is for very different habits and levels of comfort with silence and cadence and what you prefer.
当然。我认为，你知道，差异，世界上有这么多人，每个人都非常不同。我们倾向于多思考：我的个性特征如何影响我在谈话中的行为？我的优点和缺点是什么？我认为这些反思是非常有成效的。它们在谈话中表现出来的方式之一是对于非常不同的习惯，以及对沉默、节奏和个人偏好的舒适度水平。
It sounds like Nancy is being very kind here. This is a very kind question of, well, when I interact with people who need more spaciousness, who need more pausing, how can we do that? I think, as we said, strangers and new acquaintances, it's quite hard to accomplish this idea of companionable silence because any sort of lull in the conversation gives you that panicky feeling like you're failing the task of getting to know each other
听起来南希在这里非常友善。这是一个非常友善的问题：“嗯，当我与需要更多空间、需要更多停顿的人互动时，我们该怎么做？”我认为，正如我们所说，陌生人和新相识的人，要实现这种“陪伴式沉默”的想法是相当困难的，因为谈话中的任何停顿都会让你产生那种恐慌感，好像你在了解彼此的任务中失败了，
and keeping the conversation alive. But as a relationship grows longer and you know someone longer, then silences become not only okay, but really great. It gives you a place to sit and think and remember to raise topics that you should be raising with each other. So just that hack I think think, can be quite comforting.
并且没能维持谈话。但随着关系的加深，当你认识某人更久之后，沉默不仅变得可以接受，而且非常棒。它给了你一个坐下来思考的空间，并提醒你提出应该与对方讨论的话题。所以我认为，仅仅是那个小窍门，就能让人感到相当安慰。
Think about how long you've known someone. If you've known them a long time, it's OK to be together and not talking. Christina had a question about her attention deficit hyperactivity disorder. As someone who has ADHD, it becomes overwhelming for me and actually sometimes quite exhausting to be in social situations.
想想你认识某人有多久了。如果你认识他们很久了，在一起时不说话也是可以的。克里斯蒂娜问了一个关于她患有注意力缺陷多动障碍（ADHD）的问题。作为一名ADHD患者，在社交场合对我来说变得不知所措，实际上有时相当令人精疲力竭。
I'm supposed to know the social cues and asking the right questions, follow up questions and all that. I tend to jump from subject to subject depending upon what comes into my brain, which can be a lot. So wondering any tips or tricks or advice around navigating some of those challenges. What do you think, Allison? People's brains, of course, are different and that's going to produce different conversational styles. That's right.
我应该知道社交暗示，问正确的问题，后续问题等等。我倾向于根据脑子里冒出的东西从一个主题跳到另一个主题，这可能会很多。所以想知道在应对这些挑战方面有什么技巧或建议吗？你觉得呢，艾莉森？人们的大脑当然是不同的，这会产生不同的谈话风格。没错。
I think there's been a lot of, in sort of public discourse, there's been a lot of focus on ADD, ADHD, autism, and always a focus on personality differences like introversion and extroversion. And it's helpful to know those things about yourself, but when it comes to conversation, it doesn't really matter where your behaviors come from, whether you're ADD, whether you're just an introvert. If you find that social situations tend to be overwhelming or exhausting, or you tend to jump topics too quickly, I think fostering that self-awareness about what your conversational strengths and weaknesses are, no matter where they come from, is a really good thing to do because you can lean into your strengths.
我认为在某种公共话语中，人们对ADD、ADHD、自闭症有很多关注，也总是关注像内向和外向这样的个性差异。了解关于自己的这些事情是有帮助的，但当谈到谈话时，你的行为来自哪里并不重要，无论你是ADD，还是仅仅是一个内向者。如果你发现社交场合往往令人不知所措或精疲力竭，或者你倾向于太快跳过话题，我认为培养那种关于你的谈话优缺点的自我意识，无论它们来自哪里，都是一件非常好的事情，因为你可以发挥你的优势。
It sounds like Christina has lots of strengths and weaknesses just like all of us. It sounds like Christina is really creative and good at pulling together adjacent ideas and cutting to new topics quickly. The downside of that is maybe it's probably a lot of work to stay engaged on the same topic for a long time with someone, especially if her interest is waning. And that is going to be exhausting. And it is going to be hard to force yourself to ask follow-up questions if you're not interested anymore.
听起来克里斯蒂娜有很多优点和缺点，就像我们所有人一样。听起来克里斯蒂娜非常有创造力，擅长将相邻的想法联系起来，并迅速切入新话题。这样做的缺点是，可能要与某人长时间保持在同一个话题上是非常费力的，特别是如果她的兴趣正在减弱。这会让人精疲力竭。如果你不再感兴趣，强迫自己问后续问题会很困难。
And that's okay. But knowing that about yourself means you can lean into your strengths and you can constantly sort of work on your weaknesses. That's what we all need to do no matter where our strengths and weaknesses come from. We received a number of emails from listeners about how to improve familial conversations. This first one comes from a listener who called herself Ms. S. She wrote, my husband and I have been married for over 50 years. We've gone through the normal peaks and valleys
这没关系。但了解这一点意味着你可以发挥你的优势，并不断地努力改善你的弱点。无论我们的优缺点来自哪里，这都是我们所有人都需要做的。我们收到了许多听众的电子邮件，询问如何改善家庭谈话。第一封来自一位自称S女士的听众。她写道：“我和我丈夫结婚已经超过50年了。我们经历了正常的起起落落，
of any long-term or short-term, for that matter, relationship. Now we are in our golden years, and I want to make the best of every moment we can. How do we reawaken some of the excitement and depth in our conversations when everything seems to be so routine these days? Is there possibly a unique or creative routine that we might adopt to get back some of the earlier intimacy
无论是长期还是短期关系，都是如此。现在我们进入了黄金岁月，我想充分利用我们能拥有的每一刻。当一切在这些日子里似乎都变得如此例行公事时，我们如何重新唤起谈话中的一些兴奋感和深度？是否可能有一种独特或有创意的常规，我们可以采用来找回我们曾经拥有的早期亲密感？”
that we've known? What do you think, Alison? What a question. How do we get the spark back in? How do we do something? And I like this question. It's not saying like, not only how do we get the spark back into our relationship,
你觉得呢，艾莉森？真是个好问题。我们如何找回火花？我们如何做点什么？我喜欢这个问题。它不是在说，不仅是我们如何找回关系中的火花，
but is there a routine? Is there a thing we could do regularly that helps to nudge us to think differently or converse differently? Of course, there are lots of ideas that you could try. But ultimately, I think it comes down to this idea of forethought. So before you are together with each other, I think reflecting a little bit about what are some topics that will be exciting and interesting to my partner?
而且是否有一种常规？是否有一件我们可以定期做的事情，帮助推动我们以不同的方式思考或以不同的方式交谈？当然，有很多你可以尝试的想法。但最终，我认为这归结为“深思熟虑”这个概念。所以在你们在一起之前，我认为稍微反思一下：哪些话题会让我伴侣感到兴奋和有趣？
What do they want to talk about? What do I have left to discover about them? What do they have left to discover about me? Just a little 30 seconds of forethought before you see them can go a really long way in actually raising those interesting topics once you're together. In a way, we're often the least interested and the least kind to the people that we care about the most because we're just used to being around them.
他们想谈论什么？关于他们，我还有什么没发现的？关于我，他们还有什么没发现的？在你见到他们之前，仅仅30秒的深思熟虑，就能在你们在一起时真正提出那些有趣的话题。在某种程度上，我们往往对最关心的人最不感兴趣，也最不友善，因为我们只是习惯了和他们在一起。
So just a tiny little nudge to yourself of reflecting, hey, what do they care about? What are they excited about? How can we leverage that in our next conversation? It can go a long way. This next question is from Christy. I was wondering if you could give an idea of good questions when talking with teenagers. My grandson has just gone into his teenage years and I found that our relationship has really changed.
所以，对自己进行一点小小的推动，反思一下：“嘿，他们在乎什么？他们对什么感到兴奋？我们如何在下一次谈话中利用这一点？”这会大有帮助。下一个问题来自克里斯蒂。我想知道你是否能提供一些与青少年交谈时好的问题建议。我的孙子刚进入青少年时期，我发现我们的关系真的变了。
I would really like to be a part of his life in his teenage years and I have found it difficult to talk with him. Thank you so much. Have you found good ways to bridge generational divides in conversations, Allison? This is such a fascinating question. I think something to keep in mind with teenagers is that they are just learning to have conversations, even though they appear to be fully formed human beings. Learning to be a good conversationalist
我真的很想参与他青少年时期的生活，但我发现很难与他交谈。非常感谢。艾莉森，你有没有找到在谈话中弥合代沟的好方法？这是一个非常迷人且引人入胜的问题。我认为与青少年相处时要记住的一点是，他们只是在学习如何进行谈话，尽管他们看起来已经是完全成形的人类。学习成为一个好的谈话者
is probably the most important skill, and they're very much still learning it. I think as parents, or really anyone who interacts with a teenager, something I find helpful to remember is that our job is to help them learn those conversational skills. So even if the conversations we are having with them directly aren't that great, you should feel good knowing that even when it doesn't go well between the two of you, that's definitely helping them learn how to have conversations with other people, with their friends, with their teachers, with their coaches. And ultimately, that's an adult's job in a teenager's life is helping to make them the
可能是最重要的技能，而他们确实还在学习中。我认为作为父母，或者任何与青少年互动的人，我发现记住的一点很有帮助，那就是我们的工作是帮助他们学习那些谈话技巧。所以即使我们与他们进行的谈话本身并不那么好，你也应该感到欣慰，因为即使你们之间谈得不顺利，那也绝对是在帮助他们学习如何与其他人、与他们的朋友、与他们的老师、与他们的教练进行谈话。最终，成年人在青少年生活中的工作就是帮助他们成为
best person they can be. And so in a way, it's almost not about you, even though I know we all want to have delightful conversations with our teenagers, but you shouldn't expect every conversation with a teenager to be deeply rewarding or great, or they're not going to always give you compliments, they're not going to ask you questions back, you're not going to figure out what the right questions to ask them are,
他们能成为的最好的人。所以从某种意义上说，这几乎与你无关，尽管我知道我们都想与我们的青少年进行愉快的谈话，但你不应该期望与青少年的每一次谈话都深刻且有益，或者他们不会总是给你赞美，他们不会反过来问你问题，你也不会弄清楚问他们什么样的问题才是正确的，
they don't want to share everything about who they are, what they're thinking about, because they don't know. They don't know who they are yet. They're just figuring it out. And so giving ourselves and certainly giving some grace to our teenagers is a great mindset to have. A listener named Becky had a follow-up question about how to help younger people become better conversationalists. Here she is.
他们不想分享关于他们是谁、他们在想什么的每一件事，因为他们自己也不知道。他们还不知道自己是谁。他们只是在摸索。所以给自己，当然也给我们的青少年一些宽容，是一种很好的心态。一位名叫贝基的听众提出了一个关于如何帮助年轻人成为更好的谈话者的后续问题。她在这里。
What would be five things that you would tell a kid to help them grow into being a better conversationalist, especially with some of our kids that have traumas in their past and maybe don't have great conversationalists around them? Thank you. What do you think, Allison? Is there a cheat sheet? There is. I mean, it's my whole book, right? It's all of the things in the talk framework. Prep topics before a conversation starts. I think that could help a ton of kids, just a tiny bit of forethought.
你会告诉孩子哪五件事来帮助他们成长为更好的谈话者，特别是对于我们那些过去有创伤、身边可能没有优秀谈话者的孩子？谢谢。你觉得呢，艾莉森？有作弊清单吗？有的。我的整本书就是，对吧？这就是“谈话”框架中的所有内容。在谈话开始前准备话题。我认为这可以帮助很多孩子，只需要一点点深思熟虑。
Switch topics confidently when they start to lag. Have a mindset to ask more questions. If you're a kid or a teenager who can even ask one question per conversation, it's going to be such a huge win for you, especially follow-up questions. I mean, you hear a teenager ask a follow-up question and you're like, wow, that kid is amazing. Giving people compliments. If you think something nice in your mind about someone, say it out loud. It shows that you are confident and competent and you really care about people. Yeah, sort of all of the things
当话题开始滞后时，自信地转换话题。保持多问问题的心态。如果你是一个孩子或青少年，甚至能在每次谈话中问一个问题，这对你来说都将是一个巨大的胜利，尤其是后续问题。我的意思是，你听到一个青少年问后续问题，你会觉得：“哇，那个孩子太棒了。”给予人们赞美。如果你心里想到关于某人的好话，大声说出来。这表明你自信、有能力，并且你真的很关心别人。是的，基本上就是所有
that we've been talking about, Shankar, the more that we can help our kids learn to do those things, the better they're gonna do in their lives. So good conversations require a partner who is willing or eager to engage. Many people struggle to find such a person. This last question is about how we can help loved ones to have better conversations with us. Here's the question from a listener who asked to remain anonymous.
我们一直在谈论的事情，尚卡尔，我们越能帮助我们的孩子学习做这些事情，他们在生活中就会做得越好。所以，好的谈话需要一个愿意或渴望参与的伙伴。许多人努力寻找这样的人。最后一个问题是关于我们如何帮助亲人与我们进行更好的谈话。这是来自一位要求保持匿名的听众的问题。
After almost 30 years of marriage, I have not been able to find a way who asked to remain anonymous. After almost 30 years of marriage, I have not been able to find a way to talk to my husband about how we interact, how we talk to each other, without making him feel defensive. Even if I include myself in how I would like us to change our dynamic in order to be more constructive, his instinct is to close up and not hear what I say or to mishear it.
结婚近30年后，我一直没能找到一种方法与我丈夫谈论我们如何互动、我们如何交谈，而不让他感到防御。即使我把自己也包括在内，谈论我希望我们如何改变我们的动态以变得更具建设性，他的本能是封闭自己，不听我说的话，或者误解我的话。
Now I'm afraid the problem is carved in stone. Is there something I can do to talk to him without shutting him down? What do you think, Allison? I think a lot of people can relate to this question, and it's a hard one. I think we do, especially, you know, hardened over so many years in a relationship with someone, you get in habits and in ruts, communication ruts. It's why so many couples go to couples therapy is to try and sort of break out of these loops of attack and defend or the habits of sort of bickering with each other. I hear that this person has already sort of tried, hey, I'm gonna like offer, I'm gonna be vulnerable with them to try
现在我担心这个问题已经根深蒂固了。我有什么办法可以和他谈谈而不让他拒绝沟通吗？你觉得呢，艾莉森？我认为很多人都能对这个问题产生共鸣，这是一个难题。我认为我们确实，你知道，在一段关系中与某人相处多年后，你会陷入习惯和沟通的死胡同。这就是为什么这么多夫妻去进行夫妻治疗，试图打破这种攻击和防御的循环，或者彼此争吵的习惯。我听到这个人已经尝试过，比如：“嘿，我会提供，我会对他们敞开心扉，试图
and trigger their reciprocity about being vulnerable. And that doesn't sound like it's working, but that's one option. Another is literally like the kill them with kindness approach where what if you broke your communication patterns in another way that where you just start giving them lots of affirmation, lots of validation, saying all the things that you really love about them and appreciate
触发他们关于敞开心扉的互惠。”这听起来并不奏效，但这是一个选择。另一个是字面上的“用善意杀死他们”的方法，如果你以另一种方式打破你的沟通模式，你开始给予他们大量的肯定、大量的认可，说出所有你真正爱他们和欣赏他们的事情，
to make sure that you're in the sturdiest, most supportive, most wonderful place you could be. Sometimes, when you're in a happy place in that way, other people are more willing to admit or acknowledge moments of things, little failures or cracks around the edges. I mean, in some ways, I think what I hear you saying, Allison, is that when someone points out a flaw in our conversational style, especially if we've had this flaw for a long time perhaps, this can be hard to hear and it can be threatening to hear.
以确保你们处于你们能拥有的最稳固、最支持、最美妙的状态。有时，当你处于那种快乐的状态时，其他人更愿意承认或意识到一些小失败或边缘的裂痕。我的意思是，在某种程度上，我认为我听到你说的，艾莉森，是当有人指出我们谈话风格中的缺陷时，特别是如果我们可能长期存在这个缺陷，这可能很难听到，而且听到它可能会让人感到威胁。
And in some ways, in some ways prepping us, if you will, by boosting our egos, making us feel good about ourselves, making us feel secure, might make it easier to digest difficult information. That's true of all constructive feedback. Really the only way that you can deliver effective constructive feedback is if you have, you are in a really positive, supportive relationship and you have spent lots of time giving positive feedback to this person so that they know that in that moment, like, hey, you think I'm awesome, you love me, we're in a great place, and also there's this one thing that I could work on.
在某种程度上，通过提升我们的自尊，让我们对自己感觉良好，让我们感到安全，可能会使我们更容易消化困难的信息。这对所有建设性的反馈都是如此。实际上，你能提供有效建设性反馈的唯一方法是，你处于一段非常积极、支持的关系中，并且你已经花了很多时间给予这个人积极的反馈，这样他们就知道在那一刻，嘿，你认为我很棒，你爱我，我们处于一个很好的状态，而且还有这一件事我可以改进。
Because if you start from the constructive place, like, everyone's going to be defensive. It's a profound human instinct to defend yourself and to defend your ego, defend your pride. It's very hard to be receptive in general and particularly if you're only receiving negative news. Allison Wood Brooks is a behavioral scientist at Harvard Business School. She's the author of Talk, The Science of Conversation and The Art of Being Ourselves. Allison, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It's been such a pleasure, Shankar. Thank you for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media.
因为如果你从建设性的地方开始，每个人都会感到防御。保护自己、保护自尊、保护骄傲是一种深刻的人类本能。一般来说，很难接受反馈，特别是如果你只收到负面消息的话。艾莉森·伍德·布鲁克斯是哈佛商学院的行为科学家。她是《谈话：谈话的科学与做自己的艺术》一书的作者。艾莉森，非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。这真是太愉快了，尚卡尔。谢谢你邀请我。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。
Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Next week on the show, Meditations on a Life Worth Living. We continue our U2.0 series with philosopher Massimo Piliucci. He'll take us inside the world of the Stoics and why their wisdom has survived nearly 2,000 years. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。下周节目预告：《关于值得过的一生的冥想》。我们将继续我们的U2.0系列，邀请哲学家马西莫·皮利乌奇。他将带我们走进斯多葛学派的世界，以及为什么他们的智慧能够存续近2000年。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。